Hello, everybody.
Hold on.
I rearranged my desk a little bit.
Now I'm confused.
Wait a second.
My... drink... should be over here.
Careful.
What did I just do?
Nothing.
Nothing?
Okay.
I think I'm okay.
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
Someone said, almost binted.
Totally didn't miss the vortex tree.
No, it's okay.
The learning curve is steep.
Learning curve?
I have to think in this game.
Have you pulled for pajama Yuka yet?
I did.
I didn't get her.
She's not a unique, so... I only tried a couple times.
And I also wasted a mini trying to get...
Tracksuit Yuka, which I also didn't get.
I got... This is about Blue Archive.
Sorry.
I never spark for...
For regular characters, though.
Koharu Nendo.
Yeah!
Koharu!
My favorite Blue Archive character is getting a Nendoroid.
And she doesn't ever get any merch.
And I'm so happy.
I'm so happy.
She's getting a Nendoroid.
I don't even collect Nendoroids, but I will.
Actually, I recently got two Nendoroids.
I got...
Snake Nendoroid.
And I got Ryden Nendoroid.
And I'm looking at...
Naked Ry...
I have...
I have Snake smoking the cigarette.
And Ryden naked.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to turn on the streamer mode.
Han!
Stop it.
Stop it, Doki.
I think that's Doki.
Wait, how do I turn on?
Oh, streamer mode.
On.
Oh, no.
It's Laimu.
We have a...
We have our...
Sloppy Sisters...
Group chat.
So...
Hello, Laimu.
Laimu!
Yeah.
But anyway...
Glad to catch my Kamiyoshi stream live.
I missed the last few since we were back.
You missed...
You missed them?
No, I'm just kidding.
And you're back for 12 months!
Thank you!
I ate a Mike Tyson's ass.
Hi, Doki.
No!
No Doki here.
Hope you enjoy Voices of the Void.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, there's so many...
Thank you guys for all this.
Thank you guys for all the returning Puffer Ships.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Jesse, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Vivicor, thank you.
Sura, thank you.
Sandro, thank you.
Aibu, daibu.
Lollipop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop-lop.
Welcome to Puffer Ships.
Thank you guys.
Oh my god.
Ow!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
This is my first time ever playing Voices of the Void.
Actually, I know really nothing about this game.
So, um, it's very...
I don't know.
Actually, maybe anything about this game.
Maybe that it's a horror game.
Yes?
I'm not quite sure.
But I like this intro music.
It's really...
I was kind of vibing to it.
And Aliens!
I like Aliens.
Totally
normal job sim.
Yeah, we'll figure it out.
So, no spoilers.
No...
Here, let me write it in a pin chat.
No, please...
This is my first time playing.
So, please no spoilers.
Spoilers.
Or backseating.
Unless...
Requested.
Thank you.
Waving me to...
Sent.
Did I spell right?
Spoilers, yeah.
Ha ha ha ha.
It's not made on the steam engine, but it's designed to look and sound like it is.
Locomotive?
Okay.
Anyway.
I guess we'll...
He means source.
Oh.
Ha ha ha.
I was like...
Let's just start the game and...
I saw some people in pre-chat, but I'm like, we should be able to get past the tutorial.
I don't know what that means.
That makes me really scared.
Oh!
I forgot to also say...
My throat is being a little funky...
Today, so...
Might be a bit...
Shorter of a stream.
We shall see.
Be sure to enable the funny settings.
For the full experience.
It's disabled by default due to people who wanted a serious experience.
Funny?
Should I...
Wait.
For people who...
For people who have played this...
And...
For me, a first timer...
Would you recommend...
That?
Yeah, is it a one guy?
I can't tell.
Yes, turn it on.
Funny setting is better.
Yes.
Straight up good.
Funny good, funny as worth.
Okay.
These were...
There was so much here.
Like, what?
There's so many settings.
I was like, this...
This...
Oh my god.
My brain.
Where is it?
What's it under, game?
Like, look at all this.
Oh, funny setting.
Right here?
Look at all this.
I...
I barely...
I like, very...
Very minimally glossed over it.
Because I was like, what?
I don't know what any of...
Like, Max Roach is.
Funny setting?
Apply?
Okay.
Oh, we're good.
Did this change, or...
Also, I think it's...
Why is the hints and tips...
So desperate to be clicked?
Okay.
Let's start.
I'm kind of scared.
Not because of the horror aspect.
Because of...
I don't know what to expect.
Expect the unexpected.
My dog is sick.
He's watching the stream too for healing mid-energy.
Boogie failed.
I hope you and your pup feel...
Well, I...
I'm...
I hope your pup feels better.
Oh, baby.
Okay.
Start.
Oh.
Cover the cursor over the button to see the description of the game.
I think I should do the tutorial.
Sandbox.
Let's try...
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Why did it do that?
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god, it just ruined everything on my...
Oh
gosh, okay.
What the hell?
Hold on.
My entire... it just broke my entire computer.
Wait, why does it look like that?
Oh my god.
Oh no, no!
It just broke everything!
Oh my gosh, it did that thing where it resizes all your windows.
Oh my god, why did it do that?
Why?
Why, why, why?
Oh, I'm... I'm cut in half!
Oh man, it ruined all my settings!
One moment, please.
Oh.
Oh, it's so annoying.
Okay, maybe if I do this...
But then I have to resize the game.
Oh.
And then...
Okay, I'll move that there.
Did the game's resolution change?
I guess so.
It...
It's currently like a tiny window in the corner of my screen, even though I minimized it.
Okay.
Where did I go?
Oh god.
Every...
Oh my god!
Every time I try to click out, it breaks my computer.
Okay, hold on.
Hold
on.
Oh gosh.
Hold on.
I am the voice from the void.
I have to...
Vtube studio is so messed up right now.
Oh, where am I?
How...
How did it get like this?
Wait.
Am I bigger?
Yes.
Wait.
Let's...
Try this.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
Let me...
Let me move here.
Maybe this will not break it.
If I just click to...
To...
If I just click out the window...
This is the game, you guys.
If I click out of the window, it breaks.
Okay.
I'm gonna click back into the game now.
Here we go.
The game is trying to give me a free lobotomy.
I...
I had it in window mode, you guys.
On the main menu.
And then...
When I got out of window...
When I started the game...
It turned it into full screen.
And now it's doing this.
Under video settings.
Uncheck automatic screen res.
I didn't see that.
Where?
Also, JB.
Thank you so much for that.
Check under video settings.
Game?
There is no video settings.
Render?
Uh...
Effects?
Oh, oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, now let me...
Okay, apply.
Okay, back.
Okay, F11.
Oh!
Now it's so small!
Okay, hold on.
Man.
Why would they put it under effects?
Right?
Is this part of the game?
Yeah, this is the tutorial.
This is the tutorial of the game, obviously.
I'm learning how to play the game.
Okay, you know what?
We'll just play it like this.
Okay, if I click out...
Oh!
We're saved!
Okay, I have to fix me again.
Okay!
Awesome!
I think...
I think we're okay.
Yeah.
I think...
I think we're...
Why am I so far...
Hold on.
I have to fix real quick.
Why is it like this?
What?
Oh, maybe if I do this.
Oh, I'm cut off again.
Hold on.
I'm troubleshooting.
Give me a second.
Give me a second!
Maybe...
JB, thank you!
For telling me about that setting.
I'll fix all my other windows later, I suppose.
We're doing it live!
That's how you know...
It's not pre-recorded.
Did I say that I was live on... Twitter?
Hold on.
I didn't.
I forgot.
Hold on.
Um... Haunting... Now.
A long while ago.
Nano, don't screenshot that.
Why is that the first thing that shows up in my timeline?
Me cut in half.
Why?
Is chat pre-recorded?
Yeah...
That's the only thing I have to pre-record.
To make it look like people are watching me.
You know?
To make me feel a little less lonely.
Hmm... Raise your hand if you're getting purred!
Nobody's hands should be up.
You're an unpaid actor.
Me, me, me!
She doesn't pay us.
You guys are getting paid.
You're not.
Pre-recorded super chat.
Thank you!
And this is a pre-recorded...
Uh... This is... This is me.
Uh... Uh... Oh!
Hold on.
Wait.
I'm gonna commit to this bit.
Hold on.
Did you guys see that the...
Alarmo, the Nintendo Alarmo got an update?
I thought it included Animal Crossing music to begin with.
But apparently it didn't.
But I feel like Animal Crossing music...
Is the perfect...
Wait.
Hold on.
I gotta commit to this bit.
I feel like Animal Crossing music is the perfect thing to wake up to.
Why wouldn't they have it?
At the very beginning.
But what's also so funny...
Is that...
It includes...
The...
The talking.
And so...
It includes the...
Like the little Animal Crossing chatter.
So like...
You are hearing the alarm go off and the music playing.
But you also hear like...
Like...
A KK Slider being like...
And it's just kind of funny.
Wait.
Can you hear that?
I turned the music all the way up.
Wait.
Can you hear that?
Play louder.
Oh!
That was my cue.
That was my alarm cue.
To...
Thank the super...
The pre-recorded super chat.
My bit flopped.
Good bit?
Really?
That was the bit?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
It did not.
I'm cracking up.
I was really looking forward to cracking up.
I haven't cracked up in...
Plus two!
Okay.
I'm a little traumatized to play this game now.
But...
I will play it.
Welcome to Voices of the Void.
In this tutorial, you will learn basic knowledge about the game and its mechanics.
Divided in three stages.
Controls, interactions, game...
Play...
Loop?
Is this out or what?
Did I trick myself?
Oh love.
Boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, wow, boom, wow, wow, boom, boom, bah, wow.
Boom, bam, bam, bam,
bam.
I'll walk through the floating icons for instructions.
Instructions on controls, mechanics, using equipment, and other important information.
Proceed through the door to stage one controls.
Or you can skip the tutorial by going back to the venue.
Wow!
That's... Can I drown?
What's in there?
What's the point of this room?
I see... no health.
I can't die in this game.
Basic controls.
Walk.
Jump.
Sprint.
Crouch.
Toss.
While holding an object.
Okay, so E to hold the object.
Rotate.
Oh.
Flashlight.
Zoom.
Select action.
Wait, what is this?
What did I just do?
What just happened to me?
Wait.
I think I pressed C.
What did I just do?
I pressed C instead of...
C to ragdoll.
Can I just lay here?
Do I need to play dead sometimes?
Because the alien?
Tab is in the inventory.
What's this?
A compass.
Oh, everything in...
Wait, what's this?
I got glasses!
Nerd.
These...
Oh my gosh.
Total volume?
What?
Discharge...
Fluid?
Flashlight is not equipped.
Oh!
How do I get out of my inventory?
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
I have no...
Oh wait, I do have actions now.
Select action.
Compass.
Oh my god, this sound effect.
It looked like a fluid.
FL should mean fluid, no?
No?
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do.
I feel like it is.
A standard battery used in flashlights.
Oh no!
Does my flashlight run out of battery?
Oh, it's the worst mechanic ever.
I hate realism in my video game!
Hot key combo keys.
Alt E.
Quick use action.
E...
Alt?
What's the difference?
I guess you're E and then you're Alt, or you're Alt and then you're E?
E-R?
I'm not sick, am I?
Throw...
Okay, I'm not gonna remember these, probably.
Oh wait!
I thought this was Tabasco.
Grab.
How do I get up there?
What just happened?
I can hold the whole table?
Object is too heavy.
Wait, no it's not.
Too heavy my butt!
Push!
I'm gonna drown it.
How do I throw it?
Come on!
Is it stuck?
What are these?
Gas cans!
Whoa!
Big splash.
MRE!
Eee!
Oops!
I got it in my head.
Can we eat it?
Food box.
Oh wait, use.
Hold on.
Oh, you can!
Ow!
Oh, I'm not hungry.
How do I know if I'm hungry or not?
Oh, clearly I am.
I keep eating.
More batteries.
Collect.
Okay.
Oh, I could collect anything I want.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh, this is the combo.
Play around with some props.
Alternatively, use mouse wheel or number keys while looking at an object to select action.
Then press E.
For heavier objects, use E to grab or shift E to...
Shift E!
Oh.
I can't jump very high.
Maybe I should have used that...
Um, here.
Nice soup.
Wait, hold on.
We can save this.
Yeah?
There's a burger on the floor.
I collected some food with me while I did that.
Um, here's the quick select bar located at the top of the screen.
Oh, sorry.
To use the quick select bar...
Press the 0 to 9 key.
Okay.
So, like...
5...
Uh, 4.
There's a battery.
Okay.
What's over here?
Precision placement.
Hold the object in your hand.
Hold left shift.
And left alt.
Look at any surface.
Use mouse wheel to turn the object.
Press R to place an object precisely.
Oh, God.
What, do we go down or up?
Curious.
So curious.
I can't jump at all.
Wait, maybe if I shift...
Oh.
Oh, it's the Gamer Crouch Jump!
Ah.
This really is Half-Life.
I see.
My food.
Wait, what's the S stand for though?
Food is a hundred.
I'm a little...
I'm a little tubby.
Well, collect.
Take the burger.
Oh, sleep stamina.
Oh.
Whoa.
So hold on, okay.
I failed successfully, I think.
Is there a fall damage?
Let's try.
Oh, maybe not.
Whoa.
Oh, my eyes.
There is, but it's generous.
You will learn how to use your inventory and object actions.
Show me the aliens.
Oh, my God.
There's so many things to remember.
Okay.
Tab opens your inventory.
Yeah, we know that.
Look at desired item and select the collect option.
Then press E.
Alternately.
Select grab and use the alt hot key.
Use items from your inventory by selecting action key.
Tin foil hat.
What?
Is there a way I can see myself?
I want to see my little hat.
I probably look like a Hershey's kiss.
Lean mirrors.
I mean.
Crouch down and look up.
Sometimes you can.
I feel like I probably look like the guys in Phasmophobia right now.
Okay.
Put stores the item in the selected container from your inventory.
Drops the item from your inventory.
Place the deposit item on the surface.
Info gives information.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold the clips in your hand.
Equip.
Certain items can be equipped.
Yeah.
To unequip, select the equipment button on the top left of the inventory.
And select the objects icon.
Okay.
Use the mouse wheel to select the use action and then use the item.
When using the battery to swap out.
Oh, my flashlight's not equipped.
But it is.
Well, it's in my...
Wait, hold on.
How do I use it though?
Oh.
Wait.
Can I drag it?
No.
Equip.
There we go.
Okay.
So then...
Use.
Aha!
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
To use an item on an object, hold the item, target the object, and press LUMB.
Refueling the ATV with the fuel can, look at the fuel can in front and use LUMB.
Wait, in front of where?
LUMB.
Are these the aliens?
Maybe.
Fuel tank.
None of these seem to be a fuel tank.
Unless...
I'm crazy.
Wait, what's this?
A crowbar.
Oh.
When wielding certain objects such as tools, they can be used...
Uh oh.
Pressing LUMB while holding the crowbar allows it to be swung as a weapon?
Or a fire extinguisher?
What sense does that make?
What about that flesh in a toilet?
Half-Life for real, for real.
Did I get tricked?
Into playing Half-Life?
Maybe.
I was just thinking the other day.
I was just like...
Oh yeah.
I gotta get around to playing Half-Life 2.
I wanna get up here though.
It looks like we continue from there.
How do I...
Okay, hold on.
Oop.
Wait.
There we go.
Okay.
What's that up there?
Hmm.
Mysterious.
Let's see.
Maybe if I get on top of...
Oh.
Dang it.
Double space to climb?
I don't think so.
Perhaps a ghost trick.
Alt F4 to climb.
You know...
Jack Sweeney...
For like...
Because of how complicated this game is...
For a second, I really believed you.
For a second...
I was like...
Oh.
Okay.
I really believed you for a second.
I was just like...
Oh yeah.
This game uses a bunch of controllers.
I believed you.
Crouch C.
Oh.
I'm sorry?
No.
Don't be sorry.
Wait.
Okay.
Hold on.
It was a...
Shift E to push.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
I'm causing all sorts of troubles here.
Okay, come on.
Please.
Metal table.
I need you to cooperate with me.
Here.
I'm shifting.
And I'm pressing E.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait.
Jump.
There we go.
Okay.
I did it!
Oh!
Right?
What is this?
Used to make satellite reports and name tags.
Like what?
Used to read.
Oh!
Where'd I...
Where'd I put it?
Wait.
Oh.
Right click when holding.
Huh!
Oh.
Uh...
In here?
Does this game have jump scares?
There's a brick wall.
Who is that?
Is there really something in there?
Spooky, freaky.
Um...
How do I drop the note?
How do I get rid of it?
Drop...
Oh.
Uh...
Crumple.
Wait.
I can make it into a tag.
It's mine now.
My name tag.
A name tag can be set...
Can set a name for an item.
It will display the name...
Oh my gosh.
It's just like Minecraft.
Okay.
Let's see.
What do we want to...
Let's give it to...
The table.
How do I...
Uh...
Eat?
No.
There we go.
Uh...
No.
Hold on.
Oh gosh.
This is part of the tutorial, obviously.
Okay.
Hold.
And then...
Wait.
Where'd it go?
Oh wait.
It's in my inventory.
Uh...
How do I use it?
Hold.
What?
Oh.
It's gone.
That's it.
It's kind of freaky.
It's actually even more scary.
Because it's just there.
It's a ghostly reminder.
Behind you.
There's nothing.
Wait.
Okay.
Let's see what else we got down here.
Oh.
This is a drive box.
Used to sell drives and collect points.
Open the lid.
Place the drives inside.
Close the lid.
Place the box on the delivery zone.
And call the drone.
Is this a strand game?
Are these the drives?
Yes.
Oh.
You can practice by putting drives in the drive box.
Open the drives.
Open the box.
Hold the drive in your hand.
Oh my god.
What?
Okay.
Hold the drive in your hand.
Press.
And put the drive in the box.
Okay.
Hold on.
First.
How do I open it?
Uh.
Alt R.
Nope.
Oh gosh.
That's...
Oh.
Where?
Ah.
It opened up like...
What's it called?
It opened up...
It opened up like...
My...
Graphics card...
Stuff.
Wait a second.
You guys, I have to show you what it's telling me.
That I'm playing.
What is this?
Hold on.
I think it's incorrect.
I think my graphics card's a little confused.
Look at this.
This is what it says I'm playing right now.
I'm playing Devil May Cry 5.
But also with the logo for...
VTube Studio.
Yeah.
That's kind of silly.
Hmm.
Oops, hold on.
Wait.
Alt R.
It disappeared.
Wait.
Alt R.
It opened it up again.
Also, my average FPS...
Is 5,000 frames per second.
Holy cow!
Oh, I have an update for my driver.
Actually, this was so useful to open up.
Thank you guys.
Um, but how do I drop the lid if that doesn't work?
If Alt R doesn't work...
What do I do?
Left click?
No.
My leggies.
Uh, left click doesn't work.
Unless...
Uh, doesn't...
Alt...
Left button.
I'll get that when I need it again.
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
Press...
To put the...
Press left mouse button to put the drive in the box.
Okay.
Grab.
Oh, okay.
Oh!
It worked so easily.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Okay, awesome.
Easy peasy.
Okay.
I thought we were gonna have to do the precision.
I'm sure there's a mode where you have to do the precision...
Precision?
Wait a second.
What's this?
Okay.
Don't need it.
Free run.
Uh...
Thank you for the gifted.
Oh, I need that.
Can I uncrumple it?
It's pretty heavy for some paper.
Wait, hold on.
Uh, hold.
Uncrumple.
And...
Wait, hold on.
Kobe!
Wow, I made it!
Oh, where is it?
Okay, here we go.
Hold on.
Collect.
There's gotta be a way to uncrumple the paper.
Hmm...
A crumpled scrap of paper.
Holy three point!
I was once on a basketball team.
Um...
I didn't play.
I was benched the whole time.
Yeah.
Um...
Guys?
What's behind me?
I...
What was that?
I hear footsteps...
I feel...
I hear...
I hear foot...
foot...
I hear tip-taps!
And then you...
Heard the water.
Get the crowb...
I'm too scared to move!
I thought the tutorial was safe!
I'm so scared.
You only heard the water.
There was definitely...
Tippy-taps.
Dude, did you hear that?
That was someone going up the stairs.
Or down!
Wait, is the sound...
That low for you guys?
Should I turn it up?
I hear a very faint ambiance.
I'll turn it up for you guys.
Oh, it should...
Should've said something sooner!
I don't wanna get jump-scared.
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm actually scared!
Wait!
Okay, I'm gonna start moving again.
Oh!
Wait, that wasn't there before, was it?
In the water?
Um, hold?
Oh!
I thought it was in the water!
It's above...
It's right here!
Oh!
Okay.
I feel better with my crowbar.
But I don't feel good at all, actually.
What fell in the water, you think?
What was walking around?
The drone!
I'm so scared.
This is an item box.
Use to sell unwanted items.
Store the items inside the box.
Place on the delivery zone and call the drone.
This is the drone control panel.
Use this control to call the drone.
It will arrive shortly.
Okay.
And these are...
Your food and stamina are shown in the bottom left.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm at a hundred.
How?
I didn't eat.
He will drain over time.
Food can be refilled by consuming food items.
While stamina can be ref...
Restored by sleeping.
Certain food items also restore stamina as well.
There's a scary ghost in the corner.
There.
Um...
Food info.
A varied diet is necess...
A varied diet is necessary to prevent boredom and maximize food gain.
They're like, you will not live like a damn cat.
You are going to get a different...
You...
Okay.
I...
I don't know.
I've like...
I don't know how some people can eat the same thing every single day.
I'm definitely not one of those types of people.
That's why I have to possess so many different kinds of people.
Because I'm just like, I always want to eat something different every day.
There's just some people that are...
There's certain foods I could eat every day.
Probably rice.
I could eat rice every day.
But...
I couldn't eat...
If I'm just like, oh, I had spaghetti yesterday, I don't want spaghetti today.
Even though I love spaghetti.
And then sometimes I want to get pizza, but the pizzas are too big.
And then I have to eat them for multiple days.
And then I'm like...
Food is best kept fresh in the fridge to prevent spoiling.
And more nutritious when heated up.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I gotta get the...
Keypad locks the door behind the password.
You can enter the code using two ways.
Use physical buttons on the keypad or simply use keyboard...
No...
Keyboard number keys.
I'll try to enter the correct password.
Press E on the body of the keypad or click the green button.
Okay.
Was there anything else I needed to do?
Hold the paper with reports.
The one I crumpled.
Uh-oh.
Hmm.
Press LMB to put it on top.
You don't need to for this tutorial.
Okay.
Destroy the crates.
Oh, it's out of battery.
That scared me.
I'm turning it down.
Holy moly.
That was so stinking loud.
Oh wait.
Oh, the battery.
Use.
Oh, the battery lasts a long time though.
Gra...
Uh...
C...
Hold.
What is going on?
How do I...
Hold the drive box lid.
Press LMB.
Ah, okay.
Where's my crowbo...
Oh, here.
Hold.
There we go.
What's the password?
Ah.
No password.
Watch this game is so loud.
I was like...
I'm gonna turn it down a little bit.
Um...
Does it matter?
Choose.
I'm green.
So...
I'm gonna go green.
Whee!
Oh.
It really didn't matter.
I just talked about pizza.
The game...
Oh.
Somehow...
I'm so good at this.
Somehow I got directly inside the floaty tube.
Why does this feel like the back rooms for real?
When did this game come out?
This is your computer table.
It has four main...
Terminals.
You will...
Use to gather, download, process, and listen to signals.
Try to get a signal by following the directions given by the hint nodes.
They are marked...
Sequentially, step by step.
Okay.
Sorry, I thought I was about to sneeze.
Whoa.
Wait, hold on.
Nothing in the water.
Little hot tub.
Wait, I can take the floaty.
It's kind of fun.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, where's step one?
Okay, here we go.
Floor!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Hope your week has been great.
You too!
You too, you too!
We have Mint trying to reach out to Wife Maturicon.
Wife!
Okay, use the WASTA keys to move the cursor.
Shift runs a scan and gives directions to various signals.
Press enter on a found signal to ping.
If successful, proceed to the downloads panel.
I'm watching.
Oh.
How do I know?
Oh, here we go.
The shift.
Let's go this way.
Oh!
I found it!
Now, then I go to the download?
Wait, what does this say?
Ignore?
Hmm.
Doesn't do anything.
Yes, we can ignore it.
Oh, enter key!
Oh.
Weak or no signal.
Thank you guys for helping me out.
I really appreciate it.
Hugo!
Thank you for the super chat.
Don't apologize.
Thank you though.
Gotta try again.
But that's what a signal looks like, no?
Oh!
Oh, there's two, there's two.
And done.
Oh!
We got it, we got it, we got it.
Okay.
So then...
I go to the down...
Okay, step two.
Oh my god!
Wait, it says no signal.
Adjust the polarity and frequency.
Look at the bottom part of the panel.
Turn on the toggles first.
Change the polarity from the mouse room.
Polarity and the local discursion value is changing.
I touch the polarity in order to get out to the left.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Something's happening.
A planet.
Do I need to do anything?
Wait, look at the bottom of the panel.
Oh, wow.
Wait, okay.
Turn the toggles.
Oh, did we get raiden?
Thank you!
Sorry, I didn't see.
Thank you for the redirect.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm in the tutorial of this game.
It's been over an hour.
To be fair, I talked for some.
A little bit.
Wait, hold on.
I can't get out of the game.
Quiet to see your message.
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Let me do this and then I'll read it.
I'm so sorry.
Yeah.
You just discovered a planet.
Torgal, thank you for the pop content.
Turn the toggles.
Change the polarity filter by holding E.
How do I know what it will look like?
See, the value is changing.
Yeah?
But what do I change it to?
Wait for the signal to be downloaded and detected abroad.
Huh?
What do I change it to?
What do I do?
What do I know what to change it to?
Oh.
Oh, it was changing.
I was doing it.
I thought these numbers were supposed to change.
Um...
Okay, it's right about...
Right about there.
That you know.
This is actually a foolproof plan.
To figure out.
You just...
Woohoo!
And then, you know...
As long as you keep holding E, you can look up at the screen.
Okay, hold on.
E!
Wait, how do I stop it now?
Wait.
Actually, I don't know what's happening.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Huh?
I see.
Let's see.
Let's write about...
Write about...
Ooh...
Bee-bee.
Oh.
Beep.
Aw, I missed it.
Oh, no.
Okay, hold on.
I understand now.
I understand, I understand.
Bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee-bee.
Oh.
Oh, I can go backwards.
Okay, good to go.
No, don't go backwards.
Stop it.
One.
One polarity.
It's going the slowest it's ever gone.
No, I missed it again.
Something just made a noise.
Okay.
Now we need the frequency.
Oh.
Oh, it's the same thing.
Okay.
Wait.
It's a little different.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, frequency doesn't loop.
Okay, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Incoming impact.
In...
So close.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay, sorry.
I accidentally just realized I'm muted on accent.
Um...
Mito, you are a treasure.
Yohane, you are a nestle berry.
Since tomorrow, we'll be streaming.
Can I get a happy early...
Early...
Happy birthday.
Golden Foxy!
Happy birthday!
My only wish is that volume 2 of MGS collection to be announced sooner.
Maybe tomorrow.
Wouldn't that be a great birthday wish?
Gently, thank you so much for the...
Super chat...
Wait, I'm trying to read...
From earlier.
Small token of appreciation.
Quiet Knight.
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the Akazuma.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Hold on.
I'm gonna take a little cough drop.
Da-ding.
Oh.
Okay.
Now we continue.
Oh.
Uh, hello?
Wait.
There we go.
I was like, I can't look around for some reason.
Okay.
Press the save button on the right of the filters.
It will save the signal to the next panel.
Save.
Oh.
That's today.
Alright.
Um.
Playback panel.
Saved signals are listed here.
Use the play button on the very bottom left to listen to a signal.
And adjust volume using the knobs.
To the right.
From the play button.
MGS Volume 2.
MGS4 on PC.
I know.
Me too.
Alright.
Uh.
Okay.
Let's play it.
Raunchy.
Um.
We have to adjust the volume, I think.
Where's the volume?
Oh, here we go.
Um.
What does that mean?
The most...
The bottom right button saves the signal to your computer.
Hmm.
Xbox mic.
Yeah, the aliens.
With their advanced technology.
Even they can't escape having to get the Xbox mic from GameStop.
A button to the right from the volume knob is the scroll.
It allows you to scroll through the signal list.
Okay.
Visualization toggle.
Um.
When finished, insert a drive into the drive slot and press the orange export button.
Do I have a drive?
Canada!
Oh, I do.
Oops.
There we go.
Do you want fries with them?
Um.
Am I doing this right?
Okay.
Drives?
Can then either be sold or processed further at the processing panel.
Hold the drive over your hand, press L...
L...
My birthday was two weeks ago!
Maple!
Your birthday was two weeks ago and you didn't say anything to me?
Why am I just hearing...
Why did you...
Why did you not say anything sooner?
Go on the break!
You were on break!
You were gone!
I was!
Hahaha!
Yeah, I was!
Okay, let's rewind!
Let's- Oh, but I got a new chair!
It's really hard to get out of it.
Oh, gosh.
I'm gonna fall.
Let's rewind.
Two weeks ago.
It's two weeks ago.
What was I doing?
Oh.
Mabel, happy birthday!
Today's your birthday!
Oh, my gosh.
It's such a good thing that I'm here.
Yeah, it's your birthday today!
Hold on, Toma.
We'll go back to the present in a second.
I'm here to wish a happy birthday.
Everybody else's birthday who also happened...
The two weeks ago.
And you know what?
You know what?
You know what, Mabel?
I'm just gonna say this...
Out of...
My own...
Heart.
Not because...
A voice of the void told me.
I don't need no alien.
Oh, my gosh.
Why is this starting to sound like a...
Like a Hallmark card?
I don't need no alien.
To tell me.
You're doing okay.
You're out of this world.
I don't need no alien.
To tell me.
You're...
You're extraterrestrial.
Now we have to go back...
To the present.
We do it.
Oh.
It's modern day.
And I am tired.
I am worn from the war.
But, Toma, it was your birthday yesterday!
Happy birthday!
So much has happened in two weeks.
I'm not the same ghost I was two weeks ago.
I'm not the same.
Anyway.
Anyway, okay.
Let's get back to the game.
Thank you, guys.
Okay.
Computer to purchase upgrades and items from the store, as well as other functions such as monitor cameras, check photos and emails, etc.
This is what happens, you guys, when I take breaks from streaming, okay?
I get too chatty, I think.
I get so chatty.
Usually, I'm pretty good about playing the game.
Oh, sorry.
My bad.
There we go.
Um, upgrades.
Oh.
Download speed.
Whoa, whoa.
It's my birthday tomorrow!
Oh my gosh.
Let's see American.
Happy birthday!
Happy early birthday.
My birthday is the 28th of January.
No!
No, Phil, you are late.
Thank you so much for the second time.
So, I would have to sell that first though, no?
Before I can... Why does it feel like it got so much darker?
Oh, because my flashlight ran out of battery again.
I need to stop using it, huh?
For just whatever.
Okay, now that I have this...
Uh... Oh!
Oops!
Did I just break it?
No, it's probably fine.
It's probably okay.
Wait, but now that I have...
Oh, I can just go.
It's so dark now though, I'm scared.
Step four?
Was there a step four?
Oh!
Here, here, here!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, I missed a step.
Come here, you!
Uh, where do I stick you in?
Stick it in!
Nice.
Plug the drive in with signal data and press import to export.
To upload the data.
Nice.
Press the green button to begin the decoding process.
Oh.
Start.
Once finished, press the button again to process another level.
Max three.
Press the red button to terminate the process if necessary.
Why would it be necessary?
When the process is done, press import export button again.
Yeah.
Okay, so we do it three...
...times?
It seems?
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, it's quite ominous, no?
Terminate if necessary.
Ha ha ha.
I'm one of the devs...
...for Voices of the Void head of Q&A Pure.
Hope you're enjoying the game so far.
Ha ha ha.
Thank you!
Vesper, thank you for dropping by.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm still in this tutorial, as you can see, but I am...
...quite having fun.
Ha ha ha.
Thank you, thank you!
Ha ha.
Oh.
Okay, finished.
Wait, so do I press it again?
More, more, more.
Up to three times.
What does it do, though?
Do you get more money?
Or something?
It cleans up the signal.
Ah!
I missed you.
It's not my birthday.
Could you please not wish me a happy birthday?
I won't.
It makes audio clearer and makes them worth more.
Ha ha.
I see, I see.
Well...
Uh...
There's no reason to...
To...
Terminate it.
I suppose.
Someone's gonna come crashing through the ceiling, maybe.
Money, money, money.
Though I'm still really suspicious about hearing the...
The walking around noises earlier.
That really spooked me.
Oh, finished.
Okay.
That really, really spooked me.
Even clearer.
It was just ambiance?
Yeah.
I feel like one of the guards in Metal Gear.
What was that sound?
Who's...
Who's foot...
Whose footprints are these?
Whose foot steps were those?
You can play the signal after you process it.
How?
How do I play it?
Geronimo!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
What was that noise?
That was literally me.
Put it back.
Stick it back in stage three.
The ambiance in this game is scary.
Play.
Play?
Oh, import.
No?
Oh, I didn't export it!
Uh oh.
Did I mess up?
Is it gonna be broken?
Wait.
Stick it back in there.
Oh, there we go.
Export.
No, you're good?
Okay.
How do I know when it's done exporting?
Is that it?
Oh, it does say level three.
Okay, grab.
Isn't it so convenient?
I feel like a game like this...
I feel like a game like this would be like...
You know how...
When you take out a USB on your computer...
It's just like...
Safely remove hardware?
I feel like...
I feel like they would want you to do something like that in a game like this.
It's my death day today.
Chovac!
How did you...
Did you go to a psychic?
Those are scams.
Click.
No text.
Data.
Detected.
Nice.
Okay.
I finished.
I guess it gives you the option to do the other ones.
But since we've been here for an hour and a half...
Now we're done?
Cool.
Does this place look familiar to you?
Is it supposed to?
Um...
Oh no.
Alien runes.
Solve...
Solve the...
Math minigame.
Wait a second.
What?
Solve the math minigame to fix a broken server.
If the answer is more than 10, simply remove the 10th...
10th's column.
Example.
1 plus 1 is 2.
1 minus 2 is minus 1.
A...
A plus A is 16.
Thankfully there's no one here to chase you with an axe.
In case you get it wrong.
I wish there was someone here to chase me with an axe.
I got a crowbar.
I've played Half-Life.
I'm ready.
That's a...
What an odd thing to say.
Wait, how do I do the...
Repair.
How do I do the math?
Repair?
Eh?
I don't think that's how you repair it.
Oh,
they were working!
Ah!
Uh...
Six...
Four...
Uh...
Five...
Minus six is minus one.
How do I do the minus?
Uh...
Zero...
Eight...
Three...
One...
Six...
Oh, it's just one.
Zero...
Wait, so...
If the answer is more than ten, simply remove the tenths column.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I get that.
Two...
Nine...
Three...
One...
Uh...
Oh...
Wait, so then if it's ten...
I would just do one...
I think?
One...
Oh...
Nine...
Ten...
Eleven...
Two...
Oh, zero!
Wait...
How do I...
How do I fix it?
No, it's zero.
Uh-oh.
Exit.
Redo...
Zero...
Seven...
Okay, so if you remove the...
So then it would be eight...
Cause it's eighteen...
Yeah, yeah...
Uh...
Six...
Ten...
One...
Yes...
Zero...
Two...
Servers will break down over time requiring maintenance.
The two types of servers are...
Base servers.
These servers affect your signal processing speed.
Satellite servers.
These servers affect your signal download speed.
Fixing a server will require solving several simple math problems.
Okay, and reward you five points on a successful repair.
This bonus does not apply to helpers fixing the server.
Helpers?
Pull...
Three...
Two...
One...
Zero...
Four...
Uh...
Three...
One...
Oh...
They're just making silly server noises.
What do they mean?
Does this place look familiar to you?
Wham for the server.
Oh, dedicated wham.
Yes.
Four...
Zero...
Two...
One...
Right?
Yeah.
Six...
Two...
Why'd it make that sound?
I thought I saw some funny lights.
Okay.
Oh, dual record time!
Cool.
Just server things.
Okay, what's this?
Using the console, you can perform different commands like pinging antenna servers, checking satellite calibration, compass, targeting, etc.
You can find a list of commands on the right of the console screen.
Oh...
I didn't know I needed to know how to code for this game.
Um...
Uh...
Oh...
Pink...
RDS filter type shows radar entities by type.
S...
Toggle......
Yeah... S...
Set target coordinates.
Clear screen.
So now... They're...
Oh...
Oh, never mind.
They're actually still pretty noisy.
Breaker box.
The breaker box controls the power of five different components.
Each one consumes a portion of energy and slows down the rest of the component's performance.
If you need to speed up the downloading or processing, turn off the components you don't use.
Breaker components can also be controlled from the PC.
Check components tab.
Components tab?
Or is this the command?
Is this not the PC PC?
I don't have my flashlight anymore.
It's a little spooky.
I don't have it equipped?
Oh, I guess you're right, because I have... wait.
No, but it was working earlier.
Uh... okay.
Oh.
Bright and sunny day!
Transformers keep the base powered.
And you will need to be... and will need to be monitored.
When one of the transformers reaches zero power will be cut off from the base.
And the transformer will require maintenance.
To fix a transformer...
Simple press the big red button.
Transformers can be reset even while active.
What's this?
Wait.
What's that?
Can I grab it?
Wait, what is that?
It has to be that way.
Why?
Oh!
Oopsie.
I'll press C.
Instead of, uh, control.
But you can't uncrouch here, I guess.
Because I was trying to jump.
I was trying to jump up so I can go maybe go out of bounds.
Hmm.
Cryptic, huh?
Very cryptic.
Congratulations!
You have completed the Voices of the Void tutorial and are ready to begin your assignment.
Remember there are many more gameplay elements to discover.
Far too many to cover in a single tutorial.
Have fun!
Jump into the hole to complete the tutorial.
That's it?
Si!
Yeah, they didn't go over that mechanic.
Why do I need to play dead?
Okay!
Whee!
Quit.
I got a bone!
I got a bone to pick with you!
I want all the bones.
Is that really?
Yeah, I just gotta quit the game.
I think I got them all.
Sneaky!
Thank you!
I think I got them all.
Whoa!
Oh!
If you press C there, it takes you back to the beginning!
Is that what it means by a gameplay loop?
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
Turn around, inspect the tiles.
And this one sells these ones?
What is that?
Dot dot dot.
There's so many little secrets even just in the tutorial.
Just craziness.
Holy cow.
Oof.
Alright, anyway.
Menu?
This song is so awesome.
I... I... I'm really big on... Game menu music.
That, like, really set a tone for a game.
Like, title music.
This one?
Like, MGS... MGS2?
Weedy!
Thank you for the gifted...
Outer Wilds.
You know, they all, like, just totally set, like...
They're just like, wow.
Yeah, it's so awesome.
It's just so awesome.
Okay.
I guess I'll start.
I'm scared.
Story.
I think I know story related.
No, no.
I want the story.
Congrats.
You are now Forklift Space Antenna Certified.
There was a lot of info to learn.
I will be...
I will be relying on you guys.
Probably, if that's okay.
Start day one out of seven.
What in the FNAF is this?
Hello?
Oh.
Me too.
Play the...
Wait.
What's the difference?
What's the matter?
Just signed to buy my first home.
Oh my gosh, Danavis!
Congratulations!
Oh, whoa.
Okay.
Clean...
Uh, press escape to pause the game.
How to...
Oh gosh.
Pause.
Binds.
Save.
Progress.
F5.
Quick save.
F6 to quick save as backup.
Oh, interesting.
Additional game.
Place.
Difficulty options and settings.
Uh...
Custom content.
Experience.
Fun stuff.
Funny setting.
Ah!
Not recommended for the first playthrough.
You guys told me to turn it on.
Toilet paper...
Marie...
Watery...
Certificate...
Cal Joy plush.
Toy boy!
How do I get in there?
Oh, come on.
Walls don't stop me.
What is that?
Actually, this place is kind of a dump.
Wait...
But actually, this is...
Um...
Kinda horrible.
Wow, it's dark.
Oh wait, I was gonna say not the moon in the sky.
But there it is, teeny tiny.
Base.
All your base.
All my base.
Is there...
Oh, there is stamina in this game.
I was about to say, is there stamina in this game?
Yeah, it was only in the tutorial.
That I just played.
Hour and a half of.
My suitcase.
But I took everything from it.
I don't need it anymore.
I got the stuff out of it.
Oh, it's free storage.
I guess so, okay.
Okay, okay.
Uh, collect.
Not enough space.
I'll hold it.
Why didn't I arrive at daytime?
Is there a way to know how much battery my flashlight has?
Is it...
In the bottom right?
Am I covering it currently?
Oh, top right.
Oh, I see, I see.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh!
I didn't see who righted, but thank you!
Thank you so much.
Gate.
What's that?
It's a little sticker.
Is this my base?
Or is this my base?
Caution.
Uh...
A lovely lady alone.
Check him out.
Is this my base?
Or is that my base?
Not the bridge.
Okay.
Why?
Tis himself.
Thank you so much for the tag gift.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
All your base are belong to us.
Classic internet...
Meme.
Classic...
There shouldn't be anything spooky.
I...
I haven't contacted a single alien.
Oh, sorry.
There was so much on the supertot.
I couldn't tell.
I...
I only kind of skimmed it.
Cause I couldn't tell if it was a spoiler or not.
Um...
But thank you!
What's this?
Base...
Gate...
Whiskey!
What's this mean?
Uh...
Is that a watch out for wildlife sign?
Wait...
Oh, whiskey is this way.
I got all turned around.
What the heck is this?
Oh, maybe the aliens are here.
Can I go to whiskey?
What does a whiskey taste like?
Go to base first.
I wanna explore...
But I feel like this is maybe...
I can't do anything until I go to the base?
I have no space left in my inventory anyway.
Uh...
I'm just gonna keep going up.
There's so many intel...
This is huge!
This is actually...
Really large...
Land.
Base is important.
Okay.
If there wasn't creepy music, this would be so...
Relaxing.
This would be so...
This would be my ideal kind of walk.
I love taking night walks.
How...
It never fails to impress me how fluid and expressive your bottle is.
It's really cute whenever you dance around.
Thank you!
I'm always wiggling.
Is this my base?
No.
Another pillar.
How mysterious.
Is it?
It says...
Go to whiskey.
Go to whiskey!
I take a vitamin every day.
I can't say it normally.
I have no space left in my inventory for you to put all our travel supplies in your pockets.
Another whiskey!
Whiskey pillar!
But I take this vitamin.
And I can't...
Even if I...
When I tell you, I won't be able to tell you normally.
I will have to tell you...
Also, sorry if I'm moving around very erratically.
I hope I don't give you emotion sick.
Um...
But basically, it's called go to cola.
I take that.
And I'm always like, I gotta take my go to cola.
I could take these.
India!
Hotel!
Juliet!
I could...
There's a girl on this...
Base?
Base.
But this is this way though.
It doesn't...
It doesn't point to...
It keeps telling me to go to whiskey.
Wow, wow, thank you!
This is...
What is this place?
A rock.
Is this my base?
It's my base!
We're home?
Wine, wine, wine, wine.
There better not be any, like, government secrets here.
I'm gonna store all my...
All my supplies in the mailbox.
Is this just a bunch of garbage?
This place needs a cleanup.
What's this one?
Aw...
Oops.
Clear, clear.
Cancel.
Wine, wine, wine, wine.
Dang it.
That's just covered in...
Garbage!
Oh gosh, this place is gross!
Why are they allowing me to stay here?
There...
Oh no!
I don't like that.
Okay.
There wasn't something there, was there?
Or...
Was that something there?
No.
Hang in there.
Classic.
How do I...
Maybe a breaker somewhere?
Why did it save?
Holy cannoli!
One, two, three, four, pass.
Hi dog!
Headcanon...
Oh no!
Wait, I can't really read?
This... I thought...
Forget the cyber truck.
We got the cyber bike here.
What was it?
One, two, three, four?
Okay, um...
Break room.
Oh, not break room!
Not breaker room!
Oh no!
Wait, there's just drives on the ground!
Why is this place in such disrepair?
What is this place in such disrepair?
There was one...
There's a few that are down.
I know how to math.
Oh my goodness.
Lights switch by the door.
Oh wait, it works!
Oh my goodness.
I thought the lights didn't work at all in this place.
340.
Ugh!
Take?
What am I taking?
Oh!
Oops.
Uh...
Put it on the wall.
Oopsie.
Uh...
Put it back.
You flipped on the outside light at the front door.
No...
Kidding?
Is that what I did?
Wake up girls!
And there's a second...
Oh, this is such a cute mural.
Wait, this place seems like it was so cute at one point.
No?
Can we clean it up?
Oh...
Gosh...
I keep monitoring my flashlight because that really freaked me out when I turned it back on and I saw something moving in here.
Or thought...
This...
Administration...
Wait, but where are the lights then?
In here?
I don't like the mannequins.
Perfect for a maid.
Did I get...
Tricked into playing...
Half-Life...
Cleaning Simulator?
Did I get tricked?
Love the garbage clipping through the ceiling.
It really just shows how...
How nasty this place is.
Where...
Where's the light switch?
Am I...
Blind?
You think it's behind some crates?
Slowly?
It's in the admin.
Oh, I think I have to go through the garage.
Uh...
One...
Two...
Three...
Four...
Uh...
Oh, there's some MRAs in here too.
Ah...
Let there be light!
Car keys!
Oops...
Uh...
Let's collect.
Baboozle twice in one day?
Oh!
Maybe that's what I saw.
And it fell over.
Oh, that did not turn on the lights out there.
Oh, here we go.
Ah...
Okay.
Oh, and a battery.
We'll...
Collect that.
More batteries!
Okay.
Very good, very good.
We'll just collect all of them.
Why do I feel like the...
The power can go out at any moment?
Ugh...
Scary.
Med kit?
Use!
Heal wounds?
Uh-oh.
I need...
A metal pipe!
It'll be interesting to check out the vine later on.
Take care.
I also try not to let him in.
Him?
Him.
I don't know why...
I know it's faceless, but it looked like it was looking at me from down here.
Is this the delivery?
Spot?
Grab.
Maybe not.
What?
I think the sun's coming up.
Delivery drone and then...
To somewhere.
It's an elevator?
Oh, maybe.
So I guess we gotta start...
Deciphering from...
Some signals.
But I wanna look around a little bit more first.
I'm exploring my home.
Oh, wow!
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
This view!
I like the view.
What?
Nothing.
Nothing in here.
I covered my eyes.
Wow, that's a lot of fire extinguishers.
Oh my god.
Oh!
This is where the elevator goes to.
Wow, there's so many drives in here.
Okay.
We gotta get to work, baby!
Why are there...
Drives in the kitchen?
Oh, they're empty.
Oh, that's right!
It did say that we, um...
It did say that, uh...
Heating stuff up would make it be more nutritious.
It's just a dummy, dummy.
Is that a ghost?
Organic trash.
I will eat the banana.
Actually...
Shut...
Shut it!
Shut it, please!
Close the door!
Uh...
Wait, there we go.
Oh, this is like their beds and everything.
Day one Monday.
Oh, there it is.
It's...
8...
F...
50.
I...
Believe...
Oh, that must be what the actual spaceships look like...
Paper.
Wash your filthy hands!
I'm not gonna lie.
It looks awfully fresh.
Would you?
You wouldn't catch me in this place.
So pretty!
Wait, there was a basement, too.
Or there was a downstairs, rather.
My flashlight is... uh... dropping significantly.
Use.
Use the battery.
How do I use?
Gosh, I forgot.
Oh, let's just go back upstairs.
Is this like the music it plays at dawn?
When the sun is... hold and right click.
Uh...
Where is it?
Hold...
Right click.
Eh?
Oh, yeah.
My suitcase.
I forgot I was holding it this whole time.
Whoa...
Freaky.
How do I get onto... this part?
The kitchen.
Oh, I see, I see.
Um...
I noticed her stamina is at 60.
Okay, time to remember everything that we learned... before.
I guess.
Oh, that's my notepad.
Okay, there's nothing written in there.
I can't work under these conditions.
I just wanna clean!
What is this?
Drive port.
Oh, we can clear the drive.
Interesting.
Let's...
Ex... Oh, there we... there we go.
There's one right so close.
Binging.
Invalid object.
Quickscan is on cooldown.
That didn't exist in the tutorial.
Still?
Oh, wow, the cooldown is really...
Okay, we'll just keep going then.
That was long.
Sorry, my cursor just...
Cool.
It's okay, I don't need it.
Ping, ping.
Ping failed.
Is that a dead pixel?
This right here?
I was... I was noticing that too.
Okay.
Alright.
Ping!
Oh!
Everywhere.
Wish I could go faster.
Oh!
That's a ping.
Alright.
That's a scan.
Oh!
How?
How did I miss it?
Let's just go down and see if we can find...
Whatever's down here.
Anything?
Oh!
I hit the...
The ground!
Hit the ground running.
Ba-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-de-bobie-boo.
Bee-boo-babida-bee-boo-boo.
Bee-boo-bababdi-bee-boo-boo.
Bee-boob-babibi-ba-ba-ba-Boob-bada-bop-Bee-boo-bee-de-bee-bough.
How am I missing that?
I caught the first one so easily.
Oh!
I just noticed my food, too.
Wait, remain behind the blast shield while machine is operating.
Cosmic gulfs... Cosmic gulfs it throws open before our frenzied eyes.
What?
Monotone man, happy birthday!
We gotta get some MRE.
Oh, wow!
Shower!
Emergency shower...
As opposed to...
I wish I could put this back up.
Is there a way to?
Radar...
Is this... Is this me?
Huh?
I think I'm gonna turn that off.
Please?
I don't wanna see it anymore.
There's something... There's... Um...
I don't wanna... I don't wanna...
I don't wanna shock anybody, but, um...
There's more than one dot here.
There's... That one's far.
We gotta get some food.
Wait, I have food on me.
Shoot.
MRE.
Okay, we're at 70 now.
Wait, no.
Collect.
How do I put... Sorry, I keep... I'm gonna keep asking this.
How do I put away stuff that I have in my bar to recollect?
Ah!
Thank you.
Okay, let's continue searching.
My stamina is still okay, maybe.
Oh.
Wait, this one's straight down.
We're here.
I found it.
Please, please, please.
Girl, do not look behind you.
Don't say that.
How much does Mito know about this game?
Virtually nothing.
I know very nothing.
I know the tutorial.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I forgot what to do.
Wait.
Here.
Here, here, here, here.
Here, here, here, here, here.
Okay, I'll remember now.
Why
isn't it moving?
Is it foggy?
Yeah.
The red button.
Oh.
What's a button?
Wait.
Red button.
No, not delete signal.
Saved.
Scares me every time.
The two switches.
This?
That's right.
Okay, I was looking for a red button, you guys.
Oh, wow, it's fast.
Okay, hold on.
I gotta, I gotta, I gotta turn that down.
Uh, let's see.
Okay.
Wait.
No, just kidding.
Oh, wait.
Ah, buh, buh, buh, buh.
Go back?
What's a good range to get it in?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I messed up.
I messed it.
Top two bars?
Wait, I, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh.
I messed it again.
Okay.
I don't think it goes any way higher.
And then, this guy.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, we messed it.
Oh, we messed it again.
Okay, good enough.
Good, good enough.
Okay, save.
I don't like the thunder.
Doesn't work.
I gotta go get a drive, don't I?
Paper.
But it's downloading, right?
Or what is... downloading, yeah.
Oh gosh, it's so slow.
Who's getting closer?
No, he's still so far.
He's still the same length away.
I think.
They wouldn't have anything too evil happen on the first day, right?
Where do I sleep at?
Like, where can I go to sleep?
Kitchen room.
Upstairs, okay.
Okay.
It was, uh, not that room.
This one.
Thank you so much for the 20th, thank you!
Oh, and there's lots of drives here too.
We'll collect a con- a couple of these.
Don't I need the paper too, to like...
Um...
Don't I need paper also, to...
Do these stack?
I should also check.
Okay, good, they do.
Um...
Because I need it for the drives, right?
And this too.
Not enough space.
Dang it.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, here's my bed!
Here's?
Oh.
This is...
Peaceful.
Hmm.
Yeah, this is nice!
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
And then the creepy ambiance happens again.
Save, okay.
Cool.
What time is it?
1.30.
Oh, here it is.
Wow.
And it stopped raining.
Lucky.
What's in here?
Can't open.
It's messed up.
Oh.
Why is it pointed at the sun?
Is X to zoom?
How do I zoom in this?
Won't let me.
See, it's so calming and nice right now.
Okay.
Maybe things aren't so bad.
That guy was always in there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Maybe I should shut the door.
Close the door.
Okay.
What's the ambiance for?
Why is it so much more ambiance than before?
Okay.
It's still not done downloading.
No kidding.
There was a drive right here.
Wow.
It's really slow.
Oh.
Um.
Oh, I just realized there's a computer.
Turn on.
Activate.
Ah.
Oh.
Oh, that's right.
Email.
Hi.
Hello.
I am Dr. Bao.
Oh, no.
They wouldn't let her get a degree, would they?
I will be responsible for your daily tasks.
In short, I will ask you to do a quick task at the start of every day.
Oh.
First, I will request a specific amount of drives.
These can range from level zero drives to level three.
I understand your situation.
However, I will not request a drive you can't obtain.
The second task I will ask of you is a simple satellite checkup.
Go to the satellite.
Type in sv.hash into the server and write down the server and number in a note.
For example, bravo.
Once you've done that, put it inside the drive box and send it off with the drone.
I've left a little notebook on the table.
You can tear some pages out for notes.
You are.
No free, thank you!
Top or bottom bunk, me though.
Top bunk.
Top.
Bunk.
Cause I was always afraid...
I didn't have a bunk bed.
But I was always afraid that...
That...
What if the top bunk fell on me?
You know?
Oh!
But also, it was so cool to just be like...
High up.
Once you've done that, put it inside the drive box and send it off.
I've left a notebook.
As usual, you will get a nice point bonus if you complete these for me.
Have a nice day and night wherever you are, Dr. Bao.
Welcome.
Welcome to your new job, Dr. Kell.
My name is Leah.
Your main supervisor.
You've probably got through the learning period.
But I'll remind you what your job is and what to do.
In short, your job is basically scanning the sky for anomalous signals.
That is your main task.
Did I get duped into playing an anomaly game?
Another task is to process the data of these signals and send us the data stored on analog drives.
You will get a reward for each drive.
And if you process the signal on further levels, you will get more points.
Next task is to look after these big satellite dishes.
Hit servers and calibration.
You can recalibrate satellites remotely through the console panel.
But if the satellite server shuts down, you have to manually fix it.
The server is inside the satellites.
Alright, I think that is it.
The nuclear reactor is not implemented yet.
So you don't need to worry about that.
Gather the signals, process them, sell results to us.
Look after the satellites, that's it.
Good luck, Professor Leah.
Okay.
80%.
I guess we can, um...
Fix some of these.
Right?
Eight.
One.
Nine.
Eight.
Six.
Zero.
Sounds...
Perfectly safe.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah, sounds...
Perfectly...
Oh, this is where the console is too.
Which they wanted me to...
Type...
Something.
Six.
Oh, six.
Four.
Two.
Oh.
Five.
Fifteen.
Uh...
Two.
Five.
Four.
Six.
Okay.
I don't like the sound of them.
One.
Thank you for the claps.
Thank you!
Um...
They wanted me to...
Hold on, I'll check.
What was it?
One.
Two.
Uh...
S-V dot hush.
Okay.
Don't go, Taylor.
There...
There's a little...
Are my eyes deceiving me?
Or did I see a tiny red dot?
Wait, it's gone.
The dot that was up there.
Wait, it's...
It's still there.
Just very...
Very tiny.
You see it?
Why is it so tiny?
It's like very...
What?
Huh?
You guys didn't see it?
Oh, it was my crosshair!
What was that?
Something growled.
Oh, my tummy.
Hold.
What happens if I run out of food?
Curious.
I wanna start getting rid of all...
Wait, this might...
It's probably done by now.
Oh, so close!
Okay.
It's behind you.
No, it's not!
With two dots in the center.
Yeah, that's the most curious part.
McBag, thank you so much for the gift.
Dude!
You can buy more on the PC...
Store.
How much do I have?
I don't even know how much money I've got.
Camera bad.
Camera good.
Sleeping bag.
So I could always sleep here and never have to leave the room?
Top left?
So I have 15 points?
Glasses.
Crank flashlight.
Oh!
Uh...
Decoration!
A vase with feet.
Well, that's a lot of potted plants.
Why does this look like a slab of meat?
Cool, funny, Sweden man.
Real, no fake.
Thank you for your great streams.
Who's that?
IDP award plushie, the legend.
Pushed voices of the void to the masses.
Cool!
Whoa!
We could get glow sticks.
It's done!
Wait a second.
Uh...
Save.
There we go.
Yippee!
Oh, volume at zero.
There we go.
Nice.
Good channel.
What do I do here again?
Um...
Uh...
Does it keep...
Does it need to keep going to load?
Import.
Oh, that's alright.
Thank you.
Alright, so now...
We take you...
And we put you in here.
Wait...
There we go.
And then we...
Uh...
Vinto Xbox mic stream.
I don't have processing yet.
What do you mean?
It's right here.
I can't do it?
You have to earn it?
So what do I do with this now?
I just put it in the...
In here?
Sell it as is.
I see.
Okay.
I...
Rock fighter.
Thank you so much for the...
Tag gift and thank you.
Put drive.
Yes.
Uh...
Maybe...
Oops.
It's probably fine.
Grab.
Grab it.
Sun's going down, you guys.
What time is it?
Okay.
We got a time.
Red is empty.
Wait, what happened to it?
It had something though.
I left it in the processor.
Oh.
Ah...
Okay.
Yippee!
We did it.
Part of vine sauce.
Oh...
I see.
Should we try and find another?
Ooh.
Or should I just go to sleep?
Hmm...
Friends with Laimu.
Yeah!
I love Laimu.
Oops.
I forgot there was a cooldown.
I could sleep while it's processing.
I just gotta find a thing first.
I'm just gonna keep going right.
What's that sound?
You guys hear that?
It's very faint.
You guys hear that though, right?
Uh...
Just music?
Okay.
Oh, my flashlight.
Is that 17%?
Uh...
Wait, how do I get it over here again?
Oh, here...
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
It's gotta...
It's gotta take a minute.
It's not even seven.
Just the wind.
Yeah.
Okay.
What's that music?
Let's...
Let's just be jammed.
Okay.
If you say so.
It's music coming from...
A creature.
I wonder where that dot went.
Why is the music so ominous though?
Why is it so horrible?
Okay, here we go.
Oh.
Okay.
Ooh...
Wait, did it go up?
Did I miss it?
What?
Wait, oh.
Try a different polarity?
Oh, wait, like this one?
Ah, okay.
Oh.
There we go.
I like concentrate.
So much.
Ah.
It was at a hundred.
There we go.
Okay.
It's fluctuating a little bit, but that's all right.
And you.
Uh-huh.
Oh!
Did you see it?
Oh, wait.
I lost it.
Oh, no.
I lost it again.
Oh, it's gone.
What was that?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, which way was it?
I don't know.
I didn't see what number it was.
The detector is done detecting.
Oh, I see.
Which way?
950-ish?
Wrong.
Higher?
Ah!
Okay.
I think that should be it.
Ooh!
Save.
Save?
Why isn't it saving?
Do I need to clear the data here or something?
I gotta download it.
Oh!
I forgot.
I forgot that it takes a million years to download.
Shall we go sleep?
Oops.
My stamina's at 42.
We could probably sleep until...
The morning?
No.
What does the red 4 mean?
It used to be 3.
But it's back down to 3.
So all is good.
All is okay!
We'll clean in the morning...
Ahh...
Hello.
We're clean in the morning...
Hahahaha.
I don't even know where, how to clean!
Wow, it's getting really dark.
My stamina's getting high.
Okay, it's not getting any brighter.
Oh, it'll get... it'll turn daytime now.
Oh my god, I'm dreaming about the garbage in my... is this a dream?
Am I getting... did I get abducted?
Uh oh, wait, I think I'm gonna drown in the garbage.
I'm dreaming about the garbage in my place.
Or I'm abducted.
Um,
I'm in the back rooms.
Hold on, I'm trying to get...
My stamina!
Um, go back to bed, please.
Whoa!
What was that?
Wait, was that the drone?
Huh?
Uh oh.
Wait, it's not daytime yet.
My stamina is about to max.
That's a spooky time.
Okay.
Let's clean up in here.
Um...
I don't wanna leave.
So...
Is that pizza?
Oh, it's a metal chunk.
Um...
Hmm...
Let's see.
Let's put everything in a pile.
For now.
That looks like an origami.
I wanna like even...
Our...
Everything is horrible.
Oh...
Can't sit.
I'm just trying to grab it.
Okay, there we go.
Gently.
Oh, don't...
Rotate it.
There we go.
Ah...
Ha ha ha!
Um...
Collect this.
We'll put everything in a pile.
I'm too scared to leave my room.
I'll be honest.
I don't wanna leave.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
This is important.
We'll put it here.
Okay.
If only I had a trash bin.
But we, uh...
Not everybody can be so lucky, you know?
I don't even trust sleeping on this thing.
Let's put you...
Right there!
Oh, wow.
The trash exploded.
Like, what am I supposed to do with these?
They sell trash bags on the computer.
Yeah, but that requires...
Going downstairs.
Also, I imagine things don't come immediately, right?
There's a trash bin outside the base to the right.
Oh, okay.
Awesome.
Except it spends 40 minutes piling garbage.
The aliens...
Will just be like...
They'll be like...
We don't...
This...
This creature's a nut job.
Maybe we should ignore this place.
They do a secret ritual.
At the bewitching hour of...
Oh, look!
I found a battery!
Nice.
Uh...
Collect...
Oops!
I just collected that trash.
Wait...
Um...
Wait, what did I...
This one?
The paper?
Is this paper also...
Maybe I need the notepad and not the paper.
Or...
I think this is garbage.
Right?
Yeah...
That's garbage.
And then this is also...
Oh wait, I could just drop it.
But it's more fun to do this.
There we go.
Middle mouse...
Quick select from hot bar.
What is this anyway?
Oh!
Look how cute!
Uh...
How do I...
How do I set down...
When I am holding something?
Alt R...
Oh wait...
That doesn't work.
Not for my game for some reason.
For some reason it opens up my...
Uh...
Oh...
Windows did not like that.
One moment.
It opens up my driver.
It's just like...
Hey...
Here's your...
Here's how your gaming performance is going.
Alt R is NVIDIA overlay.
Like...
Yeah, yeah.
Similar for me.
So funny.
Okay.
Shift Alt R.
Oh!
Well...
We can grab it now.
We can...
Place it as we wish.
Cute!
It's starting to feel way...
Oh wait, I grabbed that from my suitcase now, didn't I?
It's starting to feel so much like home.
What else we got in here?
Car keys?
My certificate!
How...
Place...
Perfect.
Use?
Custom content is disabled.
Perfect.
Good, good.
We're clearing out our inventory.
And the toilet paper roll.
Oh, no, no.
Not the battery.
Wait, no.
Just kidding.
Yeah, I placed that.
Where'd the battery go, though?
Uh-oh.
Guys, I lost the battery.
I lost the battery.
No!
I accidentally placed it!
I don't know where I placed it!
How did that fall?
Oh my gosh, this scared me.
Collect.
How'd you fall?
Aw, man!
What was that?
Where was my tummy?
Gosh, I'm always so hungry.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Eat.
There we go.
A hundred plus.
All right.
We'll be good for now.
We're...
Yes!
And...
Right there.
I accidentally bumped the table a little bit, I think.
Grab it.
Oh.
Wow, everything is really sensitive, huh?
Come here.
We'll take that to the garbage later.
What time is it now?
It's 530!
The sun is starting to come up.
We should be able to...
Someone said there's a garbage...
Somewhere.
There's heaps of garbage, yeah.
But I gotta make money to eat?
I think.
I wanna...
I'll be honest, guys.
I'm kinda hungry.
I was thinking of...
Are those shoes?
No.
I was thinking of stopping stream, but I kinda want something freaky to happen before then.
You know?
I wanna see something freaky happen.
Our garbage pile.
Garbage day!
Go eat.
I will when something freaky happens.
What's in here?
Okay.
Weren't there...
Oh yeah, there's MREs in here.
We'll collect those.
Um...
That's not...
Oh, look!
A cookbook!
Dough, buns, burger, steak, hot dog...
Hot dog!
Hints!
You can use the knife to slice other food like bread, watermelon, etc.
Water container is a bucket of water.
I see.
Well, I have a lot of garbage here.
Before I can...
Oops!
Oopsie!
Oh!
My flashlight just died.
How do I use it?
There we go.
Wait.
Oh yeah, that worked.
Okay, good, good, good.
I think the day is beginning.
The dawn is arising.
Yeah.
Let's go downstairs.
Boop!
You can slice water.
Probably.
Bottle.
Dawn of the second day.
Today, we search for a trash can.
That is the goal.
To find...
Trash can.
Somewhere.
Freddy starts moving on day four.
So...
Does someone come and like pick these up or...
Metal cans.
Oh no, I have to separate everything.
No, it just stores trash.
No?
Uh oh.
Then what do I do with this?
You can sell trash.
Then I'm sitting on a gold mine.
We sell...
In here?
With the drone?
Can I sell the mannequins?
Wait, I...
Open the garage door.
Oh, that's a good idea.
Wait.
Smoking.
Okay.
Wait, I didn't call the drone.
So why did that thing come in the middle of the night?
Did it leave anything?
I don't even know where it would leave.
Metal scrap.
Got a hammer.
A wrench.
Notepad.
Oh wait.
Red button near the door.
Did I miss it?
Oh, I did.
Thank you.
Oh!
They gave me MRE and drive!
How kind!
Is it because it was my first day?
Alright.
So then...
Loading bay.
Keep clear.
So if I put a bunch of junk here...
If I put all this garbo...
That'll collect it?
It needs to be in a box.
Oh...
They said you need a crate.
This looks like a crate.
Can't open.
Shoot.
I want these mannequins out of my office.
Okay.
Well, hold on.
What I can do...
Is check on the thing that was downloading.
Which is done.
Perfect.
And then we can import it.
Or save.
And then we can listen.
No, we can't.
Yep.
Sounds like a dwarf planet.
Number one.
The basement.
I'm scared of the basement!
There's an incinerator down there?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Maybe I have to go to the basement.
Now I don't have the processor.
So I just...
Grab it.
And put it in here.
Like...
Like so.
Takezo!
Thank you for the gifted!
Thank you!
Alright.
Oh.
Sorry.
Freaks me out when it...
Save.
Five?
Wait, what is that down there?
Huh?
Five?
What do you mean by that?
I don't want to zoom in.
Please get me out.
I...
Zoom out.
How do I zoom out?
Wait, I don't...
I don't wanna...
Shift?
No?
Okay, it's fine.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well, um...
Let's go to the basement, I guess.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well, um...
Oh, that's...
That's that thing.
I don't remember what it was.
Is
that it?
Wait.
Why is there no music down here?
Makes me...
Pfff.
Oh.
Wait, why is there a chair here?
Oh my gosh.
Why is there a chair?
Oh, it still doesn't open though.
Interesting.
Wait.
It's too heavy for me to push.
There we go.
Rubber trash.
Whoa!
A cell phone!
Oh!
Thank you for the raid!
Thank you!
I'm a scary part of game!
Wait, what's in here?
Okay, let's just cover that back up.
Good enough.
I'm guessing this is the incinerator?
I
need to figure out a way to move those first, I think.
Maybe.
It's hot.
I think.
I don't know what I did.
Uh...
Ducky, thank you for the gifter!
You can burn the mannequins.
Yeah, I plan on it.
Okay.
Hold on one second.
Something is like on my...
Something's acting up on my computer!
Okay, okay.
Okie dokie.
I'm acting up.
Well, quit it!
Tools to break the boxes with.
Was that a prank?
Was that a practical joke?
I think you have to equip it.
Like, hold it?
I don't wanna waste my flashlight.
Nice!
Is there anything in here?
Nope.
Go ahead.
Turn on the lights?
Oh.
It's hard to see the light switch.
Okay.
Hahaha!
We will...
Rock you!
Nice!
There's a bunch of...
Plastics.
I could...
I don't know if I should eat that.
Mmm...
Okay.
Metal scrap.
Now I can open it.
Holy...
It's kind of ominous.
The door is open.
Freaky.
Oh, there's so much wooden debris now!
Okay.
Okay, I might need...
Uh...
Rubber trash.
You're gonna force me in here though.
Clean up all the mess.
It's so spooky and dark down here.
I don't wanna be down here.
It's so...
It's too quiet, you know?
Cool!
What is that?
Rubber trash.
What is this?
Oh.
My potato!
Wait, is that the potato?
How do I get that?
Uh... I'm stuck.
There we go.
I guess that's just a bunch of scrap altogether.
Oh!
Okay.
Something happened.
Canned peaches!
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches...
Collisions.
The collisions are having fun.
Okay.
What time is it?
Time is a construct to me now.
I think it works.
That's it?
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
It left more wooden debris on the floor for me!
Open.
Okay.
It's still daylight?
Yes.
Perfect.
Hello, work... station?
11am.
Just in time.
Still...
Five...
Critters.
Oh my gosh, I thought I saw Bigfoot.
That's why I jerked my mouse.
I thought I saw Bigfoot for real.
Was that a new ping on the...
Yeah, but don't worry about it.
Okay.
Da-dum.
Let's go out.
I wish that it could tell you which ones were closer.
You know, like if it was really far away, it would be a long...
A long arm.
And if it was really close, it would be a short arm.
It does.
What do you mean it does?
Depends on the size of the arrow.
Oh, wait, it's right there.
So far.
The smaller the arrow, the closer?
No...
No way?
Jay, thank you so much for the podcast.
Are you...
Serious?
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha!
I'm Harleyge!
Check emails?
Oh, do I have a new one?
Oh, I do.
Daily task.
This is a task for today.
Two signals of level zero.
Reward 31.
Check the satellite and make a report.
Tango Sedera Uniform?
What?!
Blue Wolf, thank you so much for the 50th gift!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Okay.
Well, we're still waiting for it, right?
To download here?
Here it comes.
Okie dokie.
Wait, I can do this daily task, though.
Because I have two signals.
What'd I do with the lid?
Oh,
I have it.
There we go.
And then...
There's something about writing, I don't remember.
There's a way to get a free upgrade for processing, but you need to type...
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Thank you, Ildaren!
But...
I'm just...
Uh...
It's okay!
I wanna get it on my own!
Jesse, thank you so much!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship!
Notebook and click report.
So if I click use...
Report!
How do I get the...
Wait, I'm confused about the satellite.
Cause I didn't get the report.
Consulate the server room.
Uh...
Target...
Wait, I'm getting...
Mixed...
I'm getting mixed...
Uh...
Things.
People telling me I have to go there physically, and people telling me I have to type it in.
I'm confused.
I don't even know what...
I'm...
I'm actually confused.
Hahaha!
SV hash for satellite report.
But it says I can't access.
So do I have to go to them?
I have to go there and type it.
Uh...
Okay.
Well, it's still early.
We need...
No wonder it's so much money you get for each server.
Tango Sierra Uniform.
We'll come back to this.
How do I know where is where?
Okay.
And...
Drive.
Oh!
Oh god.
Okay.
Oh!
Uh...
Road Troop!
There's a satellite...
Right here!
Let's go see what it's name is.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
I don't think I'll get sick from this.
How do I get off?
Get me off this!
This crazy ride!
Be careful...
Falling rock.
Uh-oh.
How do I put it in park?
Um...
Don't do that.
Why?
Am I okay?
Walk it off.
Where'd my ATV go?
Um...
Ah!
That's me!
I think I have a...
Uh...
Brain injury.
Oh no.
I stopped bleeding.
We're fine.
Where'd my bike go?
Um...
Things are not going according to plan.
Uh...
Here's a satellite.
Let's go see this name.
Gravity stolen.
Hold the keys and then click right.
Okay.
Let's see what this place is first.
This is gonna be...
Tango!
Shut up Murphy.
This is...
We're at...
Uh...
Where am I?
How do I know where I am?
Top right...
Oh, we're at Echo!
Okay.
Echo...
This is...
S...
Uh...
Would you guys ever do, like, a firewatch job?
Part of me...
Really just wants to, like, give it all up and do a firewatch job.
You know?
I mean, it's not a forever thing.
Like, people go for a season or...
You know, whatever, but...
I've...
Wanted to try, you know?
But, recently, I've been...
I, like, sometimes...
Get, uh...
Fire...
People, like...
Who work firewatches.
I get them on TikTok.
And just, like, them talking about, like...
A day in the life...
As a...
Firewatch ranger.
Things like that.
Caretaker.
And, uh...
Lighthouse caretaker is my firewatch.
Oh my god.
I think I would probably...
Foxtrot!
I think I would probably prefer a lighthouse too.
But those are...
Haunted.
Perfect place for me, huh?
But, um...
I saw one recently.
I have a lady who was just like...
I work at a firewatch.
And it's, like, literally middle of nowhere.
And...
A guy...
Came to my firewatch.
Like...
Like, and she was like...
I don't know.
Like, it's very hard to...
Like, just stumble upon my firewatch.
How?
How did he find it?
How did he...
How?
I heard you.
I saw that TikTok too?
Yeah!
That's why I wouldn't do firewatch.
I think it's a very...
Oh, I see it!
I think it's a very rare occurrence...
Considering how...
Remote firewatch towers are...
In general, but...
Wow, that thing...
Got some air!
There...
Yeah!
Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
I'm...
I'm sprinting and running.
But, um...
Yeah, I don't know...
Seems like it would be just really nice...
To wake up, and like...
But I think I've...
Maybe I've played also too many horror games...
About firewatches...
For me to...
Be okay about it.
Is that my tummy?
Oh, my bad.
Holy cow, I went through two... Wait, I think I had four MREs.
No, and I went through two of them?
Hungry camper over here.
Where's my TV?
Okay, this time I'll learn how to park it.
If I can find it.
Wait.
I lost it.
There it is!
I forgot it was across the river.
Okay.
Let's drive.
Can't drive while holding an object.
I'm holding the keys.
Oh.
Watch for trees.
I don't think I can afford another accident.
I don't think I can afford it.
We're fine.
Don't worry about it.
Okay, well...
I was gonna go to that one over there, but we'll go to this one.
Because it's close.
What's this?
Charlie Delta...
Base.
No.
What are you?
You are...
Whiskey!
The whiskey...
Totem.
Okay, someone said...
Breaks.
Thank you!
Okay.
All right...
Wait, one second...
Guys...
These...
Uh...
Hidoki.
Okay.
Does...
Sprinting...
Uh...
Lower my...
Stamina?
Because, uh...
If I...
Run out of stamina...
What happens?
Lima...
This is not as effective...
How many satellites are there?
Holy cow!
There's so many!
Is that one over there?
Uh...
Oh...
Oh, here we go.
24?
Okay...
How many letters in the alphabet?
You're kidding me.
Is that my base?
Yeah.
What if I saw from far away...
Like someone set it on fire?
That'd be crazy.
Kilo...
Okay, I give up on this daily task.
I'm gonna go get the drone...
So we can at least buy some trash bags.
Server needs fixing here.
Here.
That's my job!
Wait, how do you know?
Here!
Three...
Zero...
Six...
Thirteen...
Three...
Four...
Five...
The target command on the console sets the waypoint.
You know what my brain just did with what you said?
Let's go back home.
I give up on this task.
Oops.
I didn't run into it.
That hard.
Are we okay?
Just a little bit of blood.
LOL, I tried.
You did.
You know what?
You really did.
I appreciate it.
I think these whiskey poles are just...
Testing me if I'll crash and...
Die.
I wonder what my health is at.
Maybe we should use the med kit.
I'm pulling in hot!
Actually not so hot.
It's actually pretty chill.
Oh, I gotta get that garbage away.
Okay, we're gonna call for the drone!
Oh my god.
I thought that fence was something creepy.
I thought this was like something crawling out of the bush.
What's this?
No...
Something.
Did I see a raindrop?
Yeah, we need a trash bag.
Oh, it is a raindrop!
Starting to rain.
Hmm.
Does this need gas?
The ATV?
I didn't see a gas...
Indicator.
Okay.
There...
I don't know how to put this back on the wall, first of all.
Okay, hold it.
Oh, here we go.
I figured it out on my own.
I'm...
Now, you guys...
You guys...
Are gonna fault me.
For not knowing where things are, when this is the map?
Excuse me?
Yes.
Is A our base?
Is B base?
You're gonna fault me, you're gonna be like, well you took down the map, stupid.
When this...
Looks like an eye test.
Whoa.
Is this from the rain, or...
Didn't you guys say something about fog?
Um, it's... hold on.
It says... it said, save... no.
It says I can't save.
Wait, am I not paused?
What do I do?
Radar.
Let's have four.
Save.
Uh...
Wait, I didn't... I didn't press anything.
I didn't... I didn't press anything.
I didn't try... I didn't try to save.
Maybe the game tried to save.
What's moving?
I don't wanna go towards my doors!
Chad is scaring me.
They're scaring me!
I don't even know how to lock the door!
How do I lock the door?
I think it's time to lock the door.
How do I lock it?
It's already inside.
Wait, what do you mean?
Lock the door!
It's...
Oh gosh, scary.
Use the panels beside the door.
Touch the keypad to lock the door.
I don't think that was, uh...
Wait!
Is it gone?
It's not...
The fog is gone.
I think.
No?
Still won't let me save.
Look outside!
Check!
Turning down the...
I'm turning down the volume.
I don't wanna get jump scared.
There's a hole under the desk?
Oh.
Oh yeah, I can see everything.
Oh yeah.
Uh...
Yeah.
How do I clean the window?
He's gone!
Whatever it was.
It's gone.
Oh, maybe nothing was moving after all.
Oh my gosh, it's so early, but my stamina is running out.
A sponge in the shower?
Really?
He has a sponge after dropping it into water.
Seriously?
Uh...
There's another dot.
Far, far away.
Far away.
This is like the sun setting music though, no?
This is the sun setting ambiance.
Okay, let's go get the sponge.
Even though I'm scared.
There.
Right.
See, I couldn't lock this door.
But I can lock...
This door, right?
Like that?
Okay.
Sleep demon?
There should be no demons.
Wait, why is my head tilting so much?
You see that?
There should be no demons in this game.
Only...
Aliens.
The concussion?
Okay, I'll go to sleep.
Please shut.
Shut.
Thank you.
And then we can get the sponge.
And we can clean it in the morning.
Oh.
I forgot to...
I forgot to do the...
Daily task.
Oh my gosh.
So much lightning.
Interesting.
She locked the doors?
Yeah, I locked the doors.
Maybe not all of them.
Oh, it's dark.
It's so dark.
Did you close the garage?
No.
Did you turn off the oven?
Maybe.
Did I see something just...
Zoom past...
On the ground?
My big head might have blocked it.
Oh, oh!
What was that?
Something in the trees!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
It freaks me out when I just...
Wake up like that.
Who I am!
Uh oh.
Oh.
Real ga- Oh yeah, this is the jet lag simulator.
Okay.
There's a mannequin in here, guys.
I like how the...
Freezer's called smug.
We can make shrimp!
There's a mannequin in here.
You don't scare me.
There we go.
Soap.
Sponge.
Collect.
Okay.
I got the spot.
Ew!
Oh.
Use.
What do you mean, use?
Oh.
Wait, where'd he go?
Where'd he go?
Oh.
Use.
Oh, whoa.
Uh.
What does it mean?
Boo!
Even though I put it on the ground.
Did not scare me.
It still...
It scared me even more.
Eat the soap!
I would do that if I said a bad word.
I would eat the soap.
Did your parents ever make you do that?
I think my mom made me do it once and then felt bad.
I did it on my own volition.
Okay.
That is...
I'm not dirty.
Oh my gosh.
I...
When I stay at a new place, I get scared.
And so I like to shower with the door open.
But in Japan...
They...
They yell at you.
And they're like, don't shower with the door open because it will make the alarm go off.
Lights are flickering for no reason.
Yeah.
No reason.
Right?
Did the alarm go off?
Well, I...
I just...
Don't do it, but I'm scared.
How do I get it wet?
How do I clean?
With the sponge using the bucket.
Bucket.
The toilet?
Advancement.
Burger.
Oh, I got an achievement for the burger.
Plus five stamina.
We're going potty?
Use.
Right?
How resourceful.
Um...
Use a bucket of water.
I don't think I have that.
Oh.
Wait.
Um...
Will the sink work?
Wait.
If I...
Sponge.
Hold.
Oops.
Uh...
Like that?
There we go.
Become wet.
Hold and click.
Oh.
Did that do it?
Uh...
Huh.
I did try holding it, but...
Oh!
I can heal my wounds!
I don't need it right now.
I'm totally fine.
Apparently.
Yeah, let's try the shower in the signal room.
I was thinking that one too.
Are the lights gonna go out?
Is...
Am I using too much power or something?
Oh, it's already 4am.
Um...
Well, the transformers...
Where are those?
You have to check the transformers.
They will go out.
I'm scared!
TR check to check the transformers.
Okay.
I'm gonna go back to sleep.
I do wanna sleep!
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ronnie, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I didn't lock this door!
I didn't lock this door before!
Oh!
If the power goes out, the doors will unlock.
Oh.
Should I lock the garage door?
Uh, yeah.
Yeah.
Well, I think we're okay right now.
Mm-hm.
I guess I'll just go back downstairs.
We'll try and clean the window.
So I just...
Nope.
Uh-oh.
Collect?
Is it wet now?
Wait, there's a sponge!
Oh, there really is!
It's someone's...
Glass trash!
Crouch, then left click.
Okay, okay.
I need to be holding it.
It's wet?
Oh my gosh!
It works!
How do people figure out how to do this, you know?
It's crazy.
Well, I think my tummy's growing.
No?
Actually, I don't know what that is.
Power wash simulator all of a sudden.
Been playing it for two years.
Jeez.
And like...
The full game is not out?
Question mark?
I'm doing my job as a maid.
How long do I have until...
Oh, sorry.
I've...
Oh my gosh.
I've been using my flashlight this whole time.
How long until it's not wet anymore?
Still in alpha.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rinse your sponge.
What do you do in this game?
Like, everything.
You do so much in this game.
Oh yeah.
Not a speck...
Left.
I'm kinda scared now.
Now I can see out my windows.
I can see if there's something standing there.
Well, sometimes they just be standing there.
Some sort of little evil creature.
Plushy Minto.
Whatever is there can see you too.
Shut up.
No!
The creature will be able to see you too.
My windows are tinted!
Don't say that, you guys!
They're lying.
Where do you get your windows tinted?
Vogel's been tinted.
Okay.
Oh yeah, thank you.
The transformers.
Oh no!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Okay, so tr.check.
Active...
Oh.
Wait.
Tr2.
Only has 18 power left.
Um...
What do I do?
Uh...
One.
Zero.
Five.
Oh!
I messed up.
Uh...
Five.
Two.
Uh...
Seven.
Five.
Uh...
Four.
Nine.
Uh...
I'm stressing!
I'm stressing a little bit.
Go out and turn TR2 on.
But it's on.
Technically.
You gotta reset it.
Oh, that's right.
The big button.
So one I could probably push.
And two I could push.
Three is okay.
Uh...
Twelve.
Eight.
Three.
Six.
Two.
Uh...
Nine.
Two.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many things to check in this game.
Three.
Six.
Uh...
Three.
Five.
Seven.
Whew!
It's 6 AM.
Which means...
The sun is coming up soon.
We will go outside.
Where are the transformers?
Where are they?
SV target TR2 will show you.
Okay.
This is...
The voice of the void speaking.
Here...
Wait.
What?
Drinking water?
Yes, I'm drinking water.
Is that what you asked?
Hold on.
Actually, I'm gonna drink water.
What am I doing?
SV.
You cannot save in mid-air.
What?
Target TR...
Two.
Server found.
Okay.
Uh...
Now the compass points to it.
Okay.
Why...
I wasn't in mid-air.
Was I?
Alright.
It's 6 AM.
I think we can go...
To it.
So if I equip the compass...
Wait.
What compass?
The one at the bottom?
What's it pointed to?
Which way is pointing to it?
The red?
Red arrow points.
Okay.
Thank you.
Think we should go before the power goes out.
Maybe.
Okay.
Oh.
To...
That way.
Ooh.
It's dark out.
Okay.
Oh.
But I locked the garage door.
It's fine.
Okay.
The sun's coming up.
We're fine.
I think.
I'm off the path.
I'm following the arrow.
Maybe I do need a flashlight.
50 move turn.
Hey, you try.
This game is not...
Oh my god.
You try.
I...
Was doing the best that the game is...
Is helping me out with.
Okay.
Why is everything so far away?
Wait, what's that glowy?
Is that just the sun?
Or a light?
Maybe.
Lamp post.
You can press shift or boost.
Oh wait.
I forgot to check if this needed fuel or not.
Um.
I sure hope not.
Okay.
The...
It's a little jumpy.
Oh my gosh.
We made it.
There's trash here too?
I can't escape.
Wow.
Explosive barrel.
That's exciting.
Regular barrel.
What do I use that for?
Oh, just storage?
Oh, I'm hungry.
Oh.
That's not what I meant to hold.
Nope.
Uh.
Oh my gosh.
I am so bad at...
Figuring out...
How to do this.
No.
Trip, trip.
Alright.
Um, oh.
Oh.
Let's go home.
Oh god.
You guys.
I don't know how to turn.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We're fine.
Alright, don't crash, don't crash.
Okay, yeah, all good.
I'm cruising.
Cruising downhill.
Brace for impacts, no, no.
Oh, never mind.
They put trees in the pathway for some reason.
Why would they do that now?
Look at that!
Is this making my flashlight go down?
I can't tell, actually.
Uh, I think I'd go straight.
Home sweet home!
Ah!
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Ah, oh.
Oh.
Um.
What did I run into?
Oh, this may be...
Oopsie!
Nailed it, huh?
Let's see.
Alright.
We made it home.
Let's, um...
Go through the front door.
Yeah?
You can pick up the ATV if it gets stuck.
True!
Alright, I'm gonna try and send these...
Via drone.
Oh my gosh.
My...
My window was so clean, I thought it was a TV screen.
Uh-oh.
Two signals.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
Cannot determine location.
Wait, what do you mean?
We cannot triangulate your location, Dr. Kel.
Please check that all the systems are working properly.
Servers, consoles, radio tower.
The drone will be sent out...
Oh no, we didn't get any food!
Radio tower needs to be fixed.
Climb the radio tower?
Where is that?
What?
Wait, so I can't take this?
And...
Oh, it's right out front?
Oh, okay, easy.
What was...
This one's 1111?
Oh, I was thinking of the password for over there.
For the admin room, yeah.
Wait, so they won't be able to come now?
What?
Status offline.
Yeah.
Yeah, we can't.
Okay.
Alright, radio time.
Oh!
Oh no!
With darkness and silence through the night.
What a thrill.
Oh my gosh.
That sound like a skelly man.
Hahaha.
What's that mean?
Beep, beep.
Bop, beep.
We good now?
There's even trash up here.
That's it?
Fixed?
Don't look down.
Free food.
Food.
I'm not trying to save mid-air.
Hot dog.
That's a lot of food.
Aw, empty.
Okay.
See?
They go down faster.
I know what you're trying to make me do.
You're trying to make me collapse.
You're trying to make me ragdoll and then fall to my death.
Huh?
I know your games.
I think I hear the drone.
My food.
Uh oh.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Uh.
There you go.
Wow, this is big.
All that for one drive and one MRE?
What do I do with the rest of this?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Heavy.
Oh, leave it?
Oh.
Ah, whatever.
Free box.
Play free box.
No, no.
Call for drone.
How do I use it?
Oh, you gotta wait for it to return.
Okay.
La la la.
La la la la.
I just noticed the bars on the window.
Our box!
It disappeared.
How far is he going?
And then we're gonna have to wait for him to come...
There.
That's how far he goes.
No, come all the way back.
Yeah, fire watch was this difficult.
I would not want to do it.
It seems that you just like record weather and...
You know.
How far are you in cleaning up the place?
Yes.
I...
Have made some trash piles.
And I cleaned my window...
Halfway.
We've done a lot of work.
I'll continue making trash piles.
Oh my gosh, wait.
What if instead of...
Okay.
I could create a wall with the trash.
I don't ever have to shut the door.
I hear him.
The little drone.
Where is he?
I hear him.
Oh, there he is!
Whoa, that's a big drone.
Guys, it's starting to rain.
I'm scared.
I'm scared because...
That's when the fog man comes, no?
Okay.
I locked that.
It's 11am.
You can just hit the red button to lock.
Oh, okay.
That seems easier.
What's T2 at?
I don't know, we should check.
I'll fix this first!
Five!
Uh...
Two!
Eight!
Five!
It tripped me up, okay?
Six!
One!
All right, all good, all good, all good.
All good.
I have barely done my job at all.
Wait, okay, so...
TR dot check.
47.
It's not great.
SB target...
TR...
What?
Okay.
I guess it's just rainy?
It's 11am, we could go.
Uh...
Yeah, what's the worst that could happen?
Let's be brave.
As you told, welcome to membership, thank you!
Beep!
Oh wait, it's so sunny!
Ha ha ha ha!
I got bamboozled.
Uh, uh, uh...
Duh duh duh duh duh duh duh duh...
Um...
Uh oh.
Let's grab you.
Oh wow, he's so light.
Okay.
Uh, this way.
Oops.
Watch out for rocks and trees.
In the forest.
Wait, what is this?
Is this another one?
Which one is this?
Is this the first one?
It's so close to home!
It's the substation.
Oh...
I see, I see.
Heya!
Maybe we'll take this road.
Oh, this is the first road I took!
When looking for the...
What the?
This is...
Not here before?
Huh.
Happens from time to time.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Uh...
Oh, wait.
Uh oh.
Oh no, dead end!
Ah...
Quantum.
It's still there.
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna crash!
I'm not.
Haha, just kidding.
Uh...
Which way do I go?
Bass?
What was that?
I didn't hit anything.
I don't think.
Okay, I'll try...
This way.
It's just...
I know I'm supposed to follow the red part, but it's all...
Rocky terrain.
You see?
When I try to follow it.
Okay.
Uh oh.
Um...
We're fine.
Again?
Oh!
How did we live?
Wait, why is it trying to save?
Uh, the game...
Oh, I think it's just autosaving.
Oh!
Oh yeah!
Oh yeah, baby!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice!
It's kind of unfair though that...
It's taking me so off the road.
I think I see it.
Yes!
We'll take the path back.
See where it...
Which...
Which way we were supposed to go.
Victor Papa.
Oh, here's...
Oh, it's still at 41.
Toolbox.
MRE.
Take that.
Take all that.
This plant has worked.
Smiley days.
Refill your...
How do I fill it up?
My AT...
Oh.
Oops.
Smiley.
Ooh!
Just put the canteen on top of it.
Cool!
Hold the gas can and click ATV.
Oh, it's that little hole in the front, huh?
Oh.
Don't cause any sparks.
We'll get it someday.
I hurt...
I hurt it a little bit.
Unless it's empty.
Let's try another.
Alright.
Maybe this is how the trash accumulated.
Careful.
Nice!
How do I know how full it is though?
I don't see anything.
Is it the 77?
You can look at the cap.
Oh.
Look at the handlebars.
Oh!
I see.
Let's go home.
Oops.
Everything's fine.
We're just gliding.
We're just...
Sliding along.
Gliding along.
I don't know what that said.
How do I get home?
Um.
Wait.
How do I get home?
I can just...
Yeah.
I think I'm following the right way.
Oh.
I'm a good driver.
Just hold on.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
We're almost here.
Cause that's the mysterious pole.
Okay, guys.
I wanna see a creature.
I'm gonna stay up.
Cause I'm also getting tired.
My voice is starting to get a little...
I don't even know how long I've been streaming for.
I wanna see a creature.
So we're gonna do our best.
To see a dang creature.
Four hours?
Oh wow.
I said that today might be a short stream.
But I'm having fun.
So...
I can activate this camera.
How do I see it?
Wait, where do I go to see the camera?
Got your package, Dr. Kel.
But the hash codes are not complete.
Please complete the task.
I forgot to do the paper.
I'd rather not.
Thank you so much for the ticket, dude.
Please redo the full rep...
Oh!
Oh, wait.
No, I forgot about that.
10 points have been successfully...
Or has been sent to your account balance.
These are okay, but our systems can't recognize anything useful.
Try to find something more interesting than that.
What are you talking about?
What is she talking about?
Camera is in the top of PC?
Oh yeah, I haven't checked the radar in a bit.
Oh, we're at four?
What is that up there?
I want to go check.
I want to go see...
My download stopped.
I don't think...
I wasn't...
I haven't done this yet.
For...
Whatever we found, actually.
So I guess I can do that right now.
Oh, okay, good.
Tab on the PC.
Okay, thank you.
Oh.
Oh, so close.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
Camera.
It's not though.
Oh my god!
That's outside!
Remote keyboard control module is missing.
Whoa!
That's freaky.
That's so freaky!
That's a good angle, I'd say.
Like that.
Not even Solid Snake could crawl under that.
Yeah, it's analog horror, pretty much.
And...
Yeel.
Oh, wait.
It was actually so close already.
That's so funny.
How?
Perfect!
I'm a bit of a genius.
Alright, now our download is going.
What if he uses a chaff grenade?
Impossible.
You think that thing is still there?
I can't tell if it moved.
I don't think so.
Oh.
But I wanna go see it.
Wait, it did?
It got closer?
No, it didn't.
You swear.
There.
Hold on.
I can zoom in, no?
Uh, how did I zoom in before?
Oh!
Wait, that...
Looks closer.
Oh.
That, um...
Wait.
Oh.
I think that is moving.
Oh, I think...
Whatever that is, it's approaching.
Oh.
It's a...
It's a moving.
Oh!
Um...
It's coming close!
Uh...
I think...
Maybe we should lock the door.
Wait a second.
I think it's...
Leaving now, no?
Oh.
I'm hungry.
Ah, it's not coming...
It's not...
Coming away any...
Or...
It's going away now.
It's not coming...
Towards...
It's like stopped.
Maybe you sensed that the doors were unlocked.
Aw, man.
No!
I was so ready to see it from the window.
Aw, man.
No, I wanted to see it.
I guess we could...
What if we went to its coordinates?
It's probably a deer.
There's animals in this game?
I still wonder why there's so many...
Five.
I still wonder why there's so many dots where I'm at.
It's kind of freaky.
I don't have to live.
If I die, I don't...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, it totally moved.
It's getting closer.
One is you, one is the tower, one is the ATV.
Ohhhhh.
Oh, it's getting closer.
Again.
Maybe I should eat and sleep.
Go meet it.
But... How do I set a point for the, uh... For the... For the dot.
Oh, wait, it's back where it originally was.
Enter key?
Wait.
I want to do, like, a hard save.
Oh, there is no hard save.
Goodbye, home.
Oh.
Uh... Can it go in the water?
We'll just cross the bridge, just in case.
I don't want it to get too far away from me, you know?
Since it was moving pretty... quickly, it seems.
What if it's something freaky?
I'm kind of scared.
But I'll be brave.
I ran over something.
Okay, we need to get back on the path.
Um... How do I get up there?
Speed!
Wow, I got an achievement.
We flipped, baby.
This way.
Wait.
Opposite?
Huh?
I went past it.
Maybe I moved?
Aw...
There's a lot of rocks here.
I'll be careful.
Is it the whiskey pole?
I didn't see my sick flip and...
I got intimidated.
It's like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I can't go...
Over there?
That guy is way too cool.
That guy...
Did you see that?
Did that thing?
He's way too cool.
Wait, how do I get home?
Okay, home.
Home, I'm back.
Um...
Whatever it was...
Is...
Maybe inside my house.
God, that scared me.
I think I hit...
Um...
I think I hit a rock.
It's down the floor.
Huh.
That's gone.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Mint too scary.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
I want to see something spooky.
Maybe I'll just let my sanity drain.
Or my stamina, I mean.
And then I'll call it, because I'm starting to get...
Eepy sleepy.
Eepy eepy.
I saw you with a c-c-c-ghost.
Maybe something else will appear.
Last time you had something scary happen, you hid under your desk.
I won't hide this time.
I won't hide.
I will be brave, and I will...
I will, it's because this time, I'm not afraid if I die.
You know?
If I hide...
You have permission to call me...
A chipmunk baby.
Anything gonna appear?
Anything...
You know what, in the meantime...
Let's clean our windows, so we can see if anything else freaky appears.
ha,
ha.
Eleven monthsate, though.
Dougie Kuu!
Dougie Kuuuu!
Dougie K-RIispos Dougie K-RIipkis Dougie K-RIipkis Uh, everybody is welcome to come over, I'm cleaning my house for you!
Thank you.
I'm cleaning my home.
I thought those were cracks.
That would be even worse, I think.
Actually not, I think.
I know.
Dear Krabs, thank you so much for the tech gift of the tech-go!
But this in and of itself is pretty relaxing.
We had the... I should have... I should have gone out to see the... the fog man.
I should have gone out to see the fog man.
I should have been brave then.
What if he doesn't come back?
What if... what if...
Here, I'll go unlock my doors.
So that my home seems really welcoming.
Everybody can come in.
Everybody is welcome.
Mi casa.
Uh...
Eh...
Tu casa.
Thoughts on the game?
Would you stream it again?
Oh, probably.
I like it.
It's... it's definitely a lot.
But...
Um...
I think I haven't had...
Enough happen yet for me to be, like, totally hooked, you know?
Um...
I think mostly, it's a bit... a lot to manage.
I feel like I can only focus on one thing.
Like...
It's like, oh, I can't do my job because I'm going to fix towers.
Oh, I can't fix towers because I need to make money.
Yeah, definitely a slow burn.
The atmosphere, though, is really, really great.
The atmosphere is...
Freaky.
It relies on you getting into a routine.
I can definitely see that.
Oh my gosh, I thought those were clouds.
That's why I didn't clean it at first.
What time is it?
It's still bright.
So maybe six?
Oh, eight.
Wow.
Do things happen freakier at night?
Or...
Is that just not the case?
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
It is freakier?
Okay, cool.
You can force things through the...
Console.
What can I type?
Oh wait!
Some of you guys were telling me to type in Maxwell.
Oh, where'd the lights go?
Wow, I'm surprised everything's working.
Maxwell.
Find Maxwell!
What do you mean, find him?
Maxwell is now active.
You gotta go find him.
How do I know?
He's not even showing up on the thing.
Did he?
No?
He plays his song, you'll hear him.
Oh, okay.
He makes a sound.
The roaches get him?
Oh yeah, my download.
Thank you.
It's still at 57%.
It's working on it.
Very slowly.
My sleep?
I'm getting pretty sleepy.
So I think...
Am I starting to...
I'm not drifting yet.
I don't have the Joy-Con drift...
Just yet.
Scrub the floors too.
What am I, a maid?
Cinderella, Cinderella.
Scrub the floors, Cinderella.
It's not coming up.
Oh, yes it is.
Cinderella, Cinderella.
Night and day, it's Cinderella.
Scrub the floors, type in Maxwell.
Go outside, lock your doors.
VTuber, what are you doing?
The chat is always yelling.
Nothing yet.
What?
I'm like...
My ATV is like looking at me so...
So...
Um...
Menacingly, I'm half expecting it to like...
Become a Transformer.
Like...
Get up on two legs and come at me.
Nothing much happens in early game.
What would you consider early game?
Well, I guess...
It said like day...
Start out of...
Day one out of seven.
Is it a type of...
Is it one of those types of games?
Where you...
Only go until day seven?
I feel like it can't...
Pre-dive in armor.
Five days is early.
Oh...
Okay, okay.
Wow, I'm surprised I'm not...
Collapsed and falling over.
I'm so sleepy.
Should we go look for Maxwell?
Oh!
There it is.
There's the drift.
You won't find him easily.
Oh, my flashlight.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
My flashlight almost is out.
I completely forgot.
If I...
Get to...
Sleepy Zero...
What will happen?
Something.
We'll let it happen and then I'll...
Then I'll call it.
Who knows?
Something will happen.
I'm excited to have something happen.
I don't really don't mind slow burn games like this though.
It...
It gives you...
Quite a lot to do.
Uh...
Even when...
Um...
When...
Uh...
You know, the spooky happenings aren't happening.
I can't tell if you guys are hyping this up or not.
Good yap game.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Four still.
A24 the game.
I...
You know...
Uh...
Like I said, I'm much more of an atmosphere type of...
Horror fan than like...
In your face, jump scare, woo-woah, type of fan.
So...
To me, A24 movies typically...
Hit that on the...
Head for me and all, but...
Wait, the...
The drift is actually kind of good for my...
Watch.
I slowly move over and clean the rest.
Oh, why did it save just then?
That's kind of evil, no?
Your download will be slow if it's offline.
Oh...
Is that why it's so slow?
What?
He's here.
The eyes?
What eyes?
What do you guys see?
Eyes?
Look near the shower.
There were eyes by the shower.
Really?
Oh, I see him!
I saw them!
If I look at him...
They go away.
You see it?
Oh!
He doesn't look so scary.
He's just kind of like...
La la la la la...
Is he on the radar?
No, I don't think so.
Oh!
What's that over there?
Is that Maxwell?
Sleep?
Oh, no, no.
I'm trying to get this.
I'm trying to see what happens.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maxwell doesn't appear on the radar.
Oh, my God!
I thought my ATV was the eyeballs!
Freaky!
Really, nothing's going on out here, though.
It's supposed to be raining, but it doesn't look so...
Bad out.
Oh.
Wait, where'd the eyes go?
Am I gonna get jump scared?
Wait, I wanna get jump scared.
Wait, the eyes are gone.
I don't see them!
Whatever that is, I think it's also...
Lower your volume, just in case.
It's kind of a jump scare.
Not really, though.
Okay, thanks for the warning.
Where'd he go?
Oh, my...
My sleep!
Hungry and tired.
Worst combination ever.
I'm not gonna hide under the desk, so you can't...
Call me a chipmunk baby!
Oh...
One?
Ta-da!
Nice vantage point, yeah.
What if he comes from behind me?
Two?
Seven.
Six.
Is the lightning from him?
Or is it just a...
It's just the weather.
Okay.
Two!
Oh, man.
Uh-oh.
One!
I'm out of water.
Zero!
Uh...
Happy...
Happy New Year!
Uh...
Wait, I didn't die.
I passed out.
What?
I didn't die.
He got stuck?
No kidding?
The transformers went out?
No.
And it's daytime.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
My sponge.
Good morning, Mito.
Try loading the save.
I think it... Wait, where?
How do I load?
I think it, um... Oh yeah, I was gonna say, I think it say, like, auto-saved.
Ah!
I've never felt more blue balled in my life.
Me too!
Well... Um, I have no power.
That's pretty freaky.
Check the basement.
Just in case it's those breakers that went out.
I will try.
Uh...
Uh!
Scared the heck out of me.
Wait.
My battery is out!
What a terrible timing.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Flashlight.
Hold.
Wait.
What do you mean it's not equipped?
It is... Wait.
What did I do with it?
Huh?
What did I... It's in my hand?
I... I... What
just happened to me?
What just happened?
Oh, because I'm hungry.
Hungry equals ragdoll.
Oh, okay.
How do I... Oh my god.
I'm trying.
Okay, hold on.
We gotta eat first.
Okay, that should... That should be enough for us.
Alright.
How do I know what battery is good and what's not?
Just keep trying them?
Oh my god.
I... I can't tell which... Are all the batteries used up?
Stacking off, then try them all.
Okay, okay.
Drop.
But it like puts it back in my inventory.
I don't know which ones I've...
Um... Okay, so I can drop this one probably.
Oh my gosh.
Go, sure.
Thank you so much for the 15 minutes.
And thank you.
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold on.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just gonna try a middle one.
There we go.
I made it.
We made it.
Yay.
Okay, I'll eat some more.
Goodness gracious.
In the end...
Nothing happened.
Wait, we can go to this thing.
Maybe.
Oh.
Oops.
It's not moving as fast as the other thing.
Ah.
It's moving barely, barely.
Barely, barely.
Let's go.
Hahaha.
Did you find the...
Ah...
The rose yet?
No, I haven't found anything.
What do you mean a tree?
How could it be a tree?
Oh, you hear music.
Maxwell?
He's close.
I hear him.
Cold.
Oh,
thank you.
Whoever made it.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't see it.
Oh.
I'm okay.
Who said that this game's...
Fall?
Someone said that this game was pretty forgiving on...
On...
With the, uh...
Fall damage.
Hahaha.
We're so close.
I think he's up there.
Oh gosh.
I mean, you're alive.
Okay, fair.
I think I have to go up here...
To get to him.
I don't know.
It's so hard to tell.
He's below?
But where?
At least I get a vantage point from here.
Do not jump.
I passed him?
I did?
Oh gosh.
That light post scared the heck out of me.
Just follow the music.
I don't see it.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
I didn't mean to.
Sorry.
Where is he?
It's him.
He's right near the fence.
Oh, I see him.
I
thought he would be...
Oh yeah.
I have been saved by...
By finding Maxwell.
I thought he would be spinning.
Can I pet him?
I can't do anything.
Oh wait.
I can.
Toggle.
Maxwell.
Dingus.
Oh.
Oh, he's purring.
Okay, Maxwell.
I'm going to try and get us down from here without dying.
He was so close to home.
I'll just...
I'll just, uh...
Walk him home and put him inside.
I
have a cat!
I have a child.
Okay, I'm going to leave you here for right now, Maxwell.
How do I...
How do I drop him?
Without throwing him?
Uh...
Carefully.
Oops.
He's purring.
He's fine.
Okay.
Okay, uh...
Let's go...
Actually, I'm going to go check the radar real quick to see if that thing is even still there.
I really wanted to stop stream like an hour ago.
So...
I did not move those mannequins.
There's a second thing.
This is even closer.
Oh, that's just my ATV.
Oh, okay.
Then we're actually pretty close.
I forgot that my bike shows up on the thing.
Excuse me?
What just happened?
Did I just run into the wall?
Is that what happened?
I can't believe we found Maxwell so fast.
Everyone was like, You will never find him.
Where's my car?
Wait.
Uh...
Okay.
Let's go after this thing.
It looked like it was on the road, so...
Whatever it is.
I just want to see...
A creature.
Even if it's just a deer.
Where is?
At least we saw Maxwell.
Oh.
I passed it?
Please don't.
Uh, please don't.
Okay, I think it's good.
Oh, what's that?
There's a house.
I mean till I've been here.
How can you tell blood splatter for the fall damage?
A little shack in the middle of nowhere.
How do I get in?
What the hell is that?
I think I see a creature!
Or something.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Does that sound just...
Pinecoats falling?
Oh wait.
I don't think that's a creature.
That's just...
A plant.
I don't think I can get inside.
Aww.
That's disappointing.
You can?
No, but like...
How...
From where?
Yeah, the hole.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It scares the heck out of me.
Why is there a bone here?
Wait.
Why are there several bones here?
That's not a pinecone.
There's bones coming from this tree.
Freaky.
What's this?
Piece of paper.
Why is this all the way out here?
Hold on.
Where did I put my ATV?
Some people said to use it for, uh...
To get on top of the roof.
Which is a good idea.
You guys are so smart.
Okay.
Maybe here is okay?
Oh.
Uh.
Um.
Wait.
A little bit over more.
We got a bone to pick with those pinecones.
Okay.
Uh.
That sounded kind of...
Musical.
But nothing dropped.
Oh, I got it.
Lucky.
I'm scared.
Ha ha ha.
How do I get out of here?
Spooky.
What do you mean?
Now it begins.
What do you mean by that?
Ha ha ha ha.
I don't like that.
Trophy head.
Aw, man.
I broke it.
Boar.
Paper.
Oh.
Bloody.
Hanky.
I'm sneaking.
Ha ha ha ha.
Do you guys hear that?
Oh, why did it just save?
Why did it just save?
The auto save is my worst enemy.
Organic tr...
Oh, dang.
I thought this...
Oh, wait.
I can eat it.
Oh, never mind.
We don't like that.
Ha ha ha ha.
Um.
I guess we could...
Grab these to...
Get out.
We could just stack it, maybe.
Eating trash.
I did that, yeah.
Ha ha ha ha.
Shovel?
Where do you see a shovel at?
You guys have such good eyes.
Oh, I see it.
Oh.
Let me out.
Look inside the tree.
What, this one?
Oh.
More trash.
Spooky.
Wait.
No kidding?
We're gonna get a Wendigo?
Oh.
That's freaky.
Wait.
How do I actually get out of here, though?
Ha ha ha ha.
How actually do I get out of here?
Wait, hold on.
E.
Push.
Oops.
Collect the head first.
Okay.
Oh.
Uh.
Did it...
No clip?
Um.
Ha.
Oh, I moved it?
Did I?
Oh, okay.
I was about to...
I was about to be like...
Oh.
Uh...
I think I...
Nope.
I can't collect.
There we go.
Crap.
Oh my god.
Why doesn't it feel like I'm...
Why does it feel like I'm not any taller at all?
Hoofprints?
Where?
That's freaky.
Um.
You can make the jump from the dresser?
Wait.
From here?
Up.
Uh.
Oh, I did it.
Let's go.
Is he here?
Yeah, there's a bit of an attic, but I don't know how to... National Park.
He might be.
He's just chilling somewhere.
Make a run for it.
Okay, but what about my ATV?
Leave it?
Okay.
Oops.
What was that?
Was that him?
It was, like, kind of orange for a second.
Unless that was my vision going... kind of funky.
Luckily, we're close to home.
Oh my gosh, my old blood stains.
Josh, welcome to membership.
So we have to put the skull in the microwave.
That's what we do?
Set it to 60 seconds.
Okay.
Actual.
Apparently.
Apparently...
That's...
What we have to do.
Am I confused?
Yes.
Am I intrigued?
Absolutely.
Manual save.
How do I put it in there?
Oops.
Oopsie.
Ah, my stomach is growling even.
How do I use it?
I'll plug it in.
What?
Almost has no power, yeah.
How do I plug it in?
Uh...
There's a cord?
This?
Crap.
There we go.
Okay, easy.
Easy peasy.
Uh...
Oh, I got a...
Oops.
I got the achievement...
Unleashed.
Will we see him?
Will we see him from the window?
Hope you locked up.
Oh, the radar, we can see it on there.
That's my... my bike.
And, uh, that's us.
Wait, you saw him?
Where?
Oh!
Freaky!
Did you see it?
He won't get Maxwell, right?
I think Maxwell is safe.
Go to where you saw him?
Will he appear again?
I wanna know if he'll, like, open the door.
You know?
If he'll, like...
If he'll, if he'll just walk right in.
Wait, where'd my shovel go?
Aw, shoot.
Yeah, Maxwell's right there!
He'll be fine.
Is it in my pocket?
Oh, good.
Okay, I feel safe now.
Is it gonna be a jump scare?
Ready to bonk.
Is he gonna, like, run in?
Safe to shovel.
How will I know?
Oh gosh, it just saved.
You can shovel the trash?
Really?
Oh.
That's not exactly the kind of shoveling I thought that would happen.
Uh...
Right click.
Oh...
It's turning it from...
Big trash to...
Little trash.
Oh...
Neat.
I thought this game was about...
Aliens.
He's fine.
He's right there.
It's about cleaning.
Ugh.
I'm so tired.
I just want something to happen.
Please!
Wendigo, come get me!
Please, please, please, come to my house.
Please, please...
Yeah, we'll go outside and find him.
Unless he's, like, outside the door.
Maxwell, I don't want you to see this.
So turn around.
When mommy dies...
It won't be pretty.
He was right here.
Why did he leave?
Where did he go?
Where did he...
Wendigo?
Uh...
Oh, he left some bones.
Aw, El.
I'm hungry.
He says, El Bozo, summon the demon.
He was right here.
He'll come back at night.
Will he?
I'll go to sleep.
I should wake up in the middle of the night, I think.
Probably?
Events should wake you.
Oh, okay, good.
I saved again.
The autosave is kinda...
Kinda evil.
Whoa, we got a dream!
Whoa!
Oh.
Do I have my...
My shovel?
He woke me up.
Is he in my home?
Um...
What was this one?
Wendigo!
Oh my gosh, I thought that was him.
I summon thee!
Maxwell's fine.
He's right there.
Wendigo!
Why is my vision, like, kind of slanted?
Do you see that?
It's kinda like...
I'm fine.
Maxwell, don't look.
Wendigo!
Wait, it's still like...
bright out.
Will I hear him?
Why did you leave?
He woke me up.
First, he...
came to my home.
Did not come inside.
Left...
Walk me up out of a sleep.
Left again.
Oh, it's a random nightmare.
No...
No way.
I don't think that's a random nightmare.
Looked just like him.
Maxwell, I'm going for a walk.
Don't...
Don't come for...
Don't come looking for me.
Go get your ATV.
So true.
Please, Wendigo.
I want to end stream.
I want to Wendigo to bed.
Wendigo.
Oh, that's my tummy growling.
Where did you Wendigo?
As soon as I put away my...
Um...
My shovel.
I know this bastard is going to come out.
And be like...
Haha, you are...
You...
You are...
Uh...
Unarmed.
This game is a slow burn...
Including the spookies.
Yeah, but I summoned the big baddie.
And everyone...
Everyone was just like...
Oh, she's going to die now.
For real.
Oh, yeah.
It's coming.
I made it sound like it would happen in two seconds.
They were like...
Oh, he's coming.
Yeah, he is here.
Where is he?
Oh, wait.
Did I go the wrong way?
I think I did.
This is my first time seeing this game.
The amount of details is insane.
Hope you find your wendigo.
Oh, he's wendigone.
He took wendigo...
Like, literally.
Aw, this is where we found Maxwell.
Hey, Builder.
I know you're trying to help.
But please stop spamming.
Please stop spamming.
Thank you.
Why can't this game kill me?
Maybe I should have stuck to the aliens.
They wouldn't have done me wrong.
Probably.
Rogot summoned, noped, and started a cryptid YouTube channel.
Guys, I think I'm just gonna call it.
Wendigone for milk.
Oh, I thought the place was on fire for a second.
I was about to be like, yo!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh, I'm on break mode.
Oop.
This is really fun though.
This game was really fun.
Like I said, I don't mind a slow burn.
But...
But, I wanted to see the Wendigo.
We kinda saw him.
We kind of saw him.
We saw...
Maybe zero aliens.
I didn't do my job at all.
I got paid once.
And they said it was a bad job.
And then...
All I've been eating is like rotten food from around the base.
I...
I just haven't done...
Oh yeah, we cleaned up a little bit.
I'm too afraid to go into the incinerator room though.
You found out the books you read and read in fear.
He's like, that won't happen to me.
I'm not gonna be part of your...
Your fan fiction.
Little lady.
Oh, I just thought of...
Ugh, never mind.
Uh, how about...
Which way is home?
Is this home?
Yes.
I ran over a rock.
Okay.
I'm gonna call it here.
Folks.
Get Maxwell.
Well...
Yeah, I'll bring him inside.
Oh, it spooked me.
Try Princess.
Thank you.
We'll put him on my desk.
There we go!
Yay!
Um...
It kinda...
Actually, I just noticed the way that I like...
Cleaned this.
It looks like the silhouette of a person.
And it ended up scaring me.
When I came inside.
It ended up...
It ended up freaking me out.
Yeah, we got Maxwell like crazy fast.
But that was fun.
Thank you guys for Voices of the Void.
Thank you for helping me out with all the confusions...
Confusing.
Confusing things.
Because there was so much stuff.
That's better.
That's much better.
Yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the stream.
Um...
I'll be playing Oblivion on Saturday.
And I'm sleepy, sleepy.
So...
If I see you, then I'll see you.
And if I don't, I'll...
You know.
If I don't, I'll see you when I see you next.
Um...
Do I go take you?
This is so much fun.
If anything, it was quite...
I feel like I was psyching myself out more than anything.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
But uh...
Atumito everybody!
Have a good day.
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
Save.
Oh yeah, we should save.
There we go.
Again...
I think my...
Generators are about to...
About to go out.
That's for future Minto's problem.
What was that?
The game is not paused?
But it said paused.
Save is grayed out.
Wait, what's going on?
It was glitching.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Future Minto's problem.
Yeah!
Wait, what's the radar?
We are...
We have reached unmatched levels of...
Creatures.
Maxwell gives me courage.
If anything happens to him, I'll become John Wick.
Okay.
Oh, it's gone.
It's all good now.
Otabito, everybody!
Thank you, thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night.
See you later.
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Thank you so much for the stream.
Bye-bye!